THE- ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET. SO. THE PERFECT. SO WE
ARE THREE BILLS ARE IN
COMMITTEE TODAY WE HAVE MISS
ERIKA LEAD WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHO PRESENT ALL THESE
BILLS WE HAVE MISTER PALM FROM
EARLIER- TO TAKE QUESTIONS OR
MAKE COMMENTS AND WILL THEN GO
TO THE MEMBER AND QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOLLOWED BY POP PUBLIC
COMMENT THERE IS NO VOTE IN
COMMITTEE TODAY AND WE INTEND
TO TAKE THE KEY THROUGH TWELVE
IN THE BUDGET BILL AMENDMENT.
BILL UP TOMORROW ON THE FLOOR.
THAT IS- AB ONE THIRTY AND AB
ONE SIXTY ONE. AND I'LL TURN IT
OVER TO OUR VICE. MR FONG. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
CERTAINLY FEELS LIKE GROUNDHOG
DAY- BUT WE'RE NOW IN OUR THIRD
ITERATION OF THE BUDGET AND- SB
ONE THREE NINE THE SECOND
VERSION OF THAT. BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR JUNIOR- WHICH HASN'T
BEEN SIGNED YET- SO IT'S
CLEARLY. THE EVIDENCE THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF WORKSTILL TO
DO AS WE REVIEW AND DISCUSS THE
THESE NEW PROPOSALS BUT WAS
APPOINTED A IS THE POSSIBILITY
OF MORE FUNDING FOR WILDFIRES
WHICH MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES
HAVE REQUESTED SO TIME IS OF
THE ESSENCE. WE NEED TO GET
OUR- DO WE NEED TO GET
RESOURCES WHERE THEY'RE NEEDED
THE MOST SO I LOOK FOR TO
DISCUSSION TODAY. THANK YOU
MISTER. THANK YOU LET'S GO TO
MISS ME. RIGHT NOW I CHRIS
FERGUSON FOR- ERICA BE- WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AB
WE'RE OUT SB ONE SIXTY ONE THE
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR- AUTHORIZES
THE FULL AMOUNT OF FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION GENERAL FUND CURRENTLY
SCHEDULED FOR TWENTY FOR TWENTY
THREE TO BE ACCELERATED TO. A
TWENTY TWO. TWENTY TWO UP FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION ENFORCED
RESILIENCY SHOULD CIRCUMSTANCES
NECESSITATE ADDITIONAL FUNDING-
THIS BILL ALSO INCREASES THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING TO BE
PROVIDED TO COUNTIES OR THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO FORTY OLD
RECALL ELECTION. FROM TWO
HUNDRED FIFTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION TO TWO HUNDRED FORTY
THREE POINT SIX MILLION
REFLECTING THE REVISED COST
ESTIMATE PROVIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO THE
LEGISLATURE GOVERNOR. AND
SECRETARY OF STATE ON JULY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR AS REQUIRED
BY STATUTE- THIS BILL.
TESTIFIES THAT BETWEEN MILLION
APPROPRIATED TO THE SAN JUAN-
THE SAN JOAQUIN ADVOCATES ARE
IN CONTROL BE AVAILABLE FOR
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATIONS- AND
THIS BILL MAKES OTHER TECHNICAL
IN CLARIFYING CHANGES TO
VARIOUS ITEMS. IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT RELATED
TO HIGHER EDUCATION AND ADULT
EDUCATION ISSUES. GREAT THANK
YOU MISTER COUPON ANY COMMENTS
OR- I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR
CAN COUPON ON BEHALF OF
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST SCHEMATIC I
KNOW- OPENING COMMENTS BUT
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE
DURING THE HEARING. WHICH IS
SUNG MR FERGUSON WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP GOING TO A FULL FOREVER'S
GONNA PRESENT HIGHER READ AND
THEN WILL PRESENT THE BUDGET
ACTIONS ON THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR THEN WE'LL JUST TAKE
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS. ABOUT
TIME ON ALL THREE ITEMS SO.
IT'S GOING TO BE ONE THIRTY
TWO. GREAT AB ONE THIRTY TWO
ALL AMONG THE PROVISIONS OF AB
ONE THIRTY TWO- THIS IMPLEMENT
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID AND CAL.
IT WOULD BE INCLUDING AN
EXPANSION OF THE PELL GRANT
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS WITH
THE WORK THE PUBLIC STUDENTS TO
USE IN FUTURE UPON TRANSFER.
AND EXPANSION OF THE CALIFORNIA
KIDS INVESTMENT AND DEVELOPMENT
SAVINGS PROGRAM TO PROVIDE FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLAR BASED COMPOSITES
FOR PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS FROM
LOW INCOME FAMILIES ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND FOSTER YOUTH. WITH
SUPPLEMENTAL DEPOSITS FOR
FOSTER YOUTH IN HOME WITH
STUDENTS- IT ALSO PROVIDES THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS WITH SCHOLARSHIPS
INTENDED TO COVER THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN. STUDENTS
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE AND
OTHER SOURCES OF AID HE
COULDN'T SPEAK AND FRANKLY
CONTRIBUTIONS SUBJECT TO AN
ANNUAL BUDGET ACT
APPROPRIATIONS. AND A DISCOUNT
WHICH IS A LEARNING ALIGNED
PROGRAM AT THE UC EMPLOYMENT
THAT IS LEARNING ALIGNED
IMPLEMENT PROGRAM AT THE UC CSU
AND CCC'S TO HELP UNDER
REPRESENTED STUDENTS WITH
FINANCIAL NEED. GAIN RELEVANT
WORK EXPERIENCE- THE BUT THIS
BILL ALSO PROVIDES A OR
IMPLEMENT. IMPROVEMENTS COLLEGE
JACKSON. INDIVIDUALS MAY PRO-
REQUIRING. A SCHOOL DIST COUNTY
ALL WILL. AND CHARTER SCHOOLS
TO ENSURE THAT OUR TWELFTH
GRADE STUDENTS ARE- FILLING OUT
THE FACTS FOR THE FEDERAL
STUDENT AID. APPLICATIONS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION- IT ALSO EXPRESSES
INTENT TO CAP THE SHARE OF NON
RESIDENT STUDENT ENROLLMENT YOU
SEE AN EIGHTEEN PERCENT. AND
THEN- IT ALSO INCLUDES
PROVISIONS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES- IN
PARTICULAR IT RETIRES THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE APPORTIONMENT
THE PEARLS. EXTENDS THE STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA HOLD
HARMLESS AN ADDITIONAL YEAR.
AND IT PROVIDES OUT ONE TIME
FUNDING TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF ZERO TEXTBOOK
COST AGREES. AND OPEN
EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES. THE
TERM. IF YOU'D LIKE I CAN ALSO
A PRESENTER ON ON TH K. TWELVE
BILL AT THIS TIME- IN TERMS OF
AB ONE THIRTY- THIS REQUIRES
ROUGHLY ELEVEN BILLION IN K.
TWELVE EDUCATION APPORTIONMENT
THE PEARLS IT APPROPRIATES
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT EIGHT.
FOR A COMBINED TOTAL O THREE
BILLION DOLLARS TO EXPAND THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND USE OF TO
THE COMMUNITY SCHOOL MODELS OUR
MODEL TO ALL STREET ART SCHOOLS
IN COMMUNITIES WITH HIGH
POVERTY IT ALLOCATES ONE POINT
ONE BILLION GENERAL FUND TO
INCREASE THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA CONCENTRATION
GRANT- WITH A FOCUS ON THESE
RESOURCES BEING USED TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
SPECIFIED ADULTS. ARE PROVIDING
DIRECT SERVICES TO STUDENTS ON
SCHOOL CAMPUSES I IT
APPROPRIATE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE POINT ONE MILLION ONE
TIME PROP NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND. UP FOR A COMBINED TOTAL
OF ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
AFTER SUPPORT A MULTI YEAR PLAN
TO ESTABLISH THE EXPANDED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM-
AND- THAT THE BILL ALSO BEGINS.
IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
INCREMENTALLY ESTABLISHING
UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN WITH POLAND-
IMPLEMENT. X. ANTICIPATED BY
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX- AND IT
ALSO INCLUDES OUT PROVISIONS.
TO PROVIDE TO REQUIRE ALL
SCHOOLS BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE TO PROVIDE TWO
FREE MEALS PER DAY TO ANY
STUDENT WHO REQUESTED. IT
APPROPRIATES ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION ONE TIME PROP NINETY
EIGHT TO SUPPORT THE EDUCATOR
EFFECTIVENESS BLOCK GRANT- AND
WITH THAT I WILL CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS. THANK YOU HELLO. I
DON'T KNOW IT IS NOT COMING
FROM US AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
REFERRED TO AB. ONE SIXTY ONE.
MAYBE ONCE ONE. YOU'RE A
CHECKING OR- SORRY MY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTSWERE ALSO
COVERED AB ONE SIXTY ONE- THAT
WAS THE FIVE HUNDRED. OR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION THE
INCREASE IN COSTS FOR
GUBERNATORIAL RECALL ELECTION
ON THE FIFTEEN MILLION-
APPROPRIATED THE SAN JUAN- SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY AND
THEN THE VARIOUS TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS. THANK YOU THAT'S
GOOD OF NUMBERS FOR ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. MR. FOR
BUT I THINK THIS YEAR WHAT IS
JOB RIGHT DOWN THE LIST ON- SB
ONE THIRTY- CAN YOU PROVIDE THE
RATIONALE FOR EXTENDING A LOT
OF- THE EXAM THE MORATORIUM ON
NEW CLASSROOM. ANON CLASSROOM
BASED CHARTERS WAS THERE WAS A
REASON WHY THAT WAS PUT INTO
THAT TRAILER. CHIU CERTAINLY I
THINK THAT THE FOCUS OF THE
TRAILER BILL IN ITS OWN
RETURNING STUDENTS TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AS WELL AS THERE
ARE PROVISIONS FOR- IN THE
ENHANCED INDEPENDENT STUDY.
MOST OF WHICH APPLY TO. CHARTER
SCHOOLS. OR OR OR BE ABLE TO
OUR TRADITIONS SO I MEAN THESE
NON CLASSROOM BASED CHARTERS
EXISTED PRE PANDEMIC SO I AM
AND I DO UNDERSTAND THAT- WE
CERTAINLY WANT TO YOU-
ENCOURAGE STUDENTS TO GO BACK
INTO THE CLASSROOM BUT IT THAT
IT KIND OF THAT THAT
PERSPECTIVE KIND OF IGNORES
REALITY THAT THERE IS NO
QUESTION BUTA SHUTTERS THAT-
HAVE SERVED- STUDENTS WELL AND
THE FACT THAT NOW WE'RE IN THE
POST PANDEMIC WORLD WHERE A LOT
OF PARENTS PROBABLY WANT TO
KEEP THEIR KIDS IN A CLASS BUT
COULD NOT QUESTION BAY STARTER
SO. I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
WHY THAT MORATORIUM IS
NECESSARY. SO CERTAINLY I THINK
YOU KNOW IT AS I PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED OUR FOCUS HAS BEEN A
RETURN JUNE- IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. WHICH IS YOU KNOW
GENERALLY CLASSROOM BASED- ARE
AND HAVE BEEN THE DEFAULT
OPTION FOR MOST OF. OUR
INSTITUTIONS ROUTE PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC. OKAY I MEAN I DON'T
BELIEVE THE POINT THAT YOU JUST
GAVE ME THE SAME ANSWER DID
BEFORE SO. I'M NOT SURE THAT
QUITE ADDRESS- THE HEART OF MY
QUESTION BUT- I THINK THAT THAT
THAT'S CERTAINLY GOING TO BE A
TOPIC OF CONVERSATION THAT
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO HAVE.
BECAUSE I THINK. LOOK PARENTS
WANT THEIR KIDS IN SAFE
ENVIRONMENTS AND BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC THEY MOVED THEIR KIDS
INTO NON CLASSROOM BASED
ENVIRONMENTS. AND SO WE HAVE TO
SUPPORT THOSE PARENTS- AS WELL.
IN TERMS OF JUST THE BIG- THE
BROAD DISCUSSION THERE IS A AND
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF ONE
TIME FUNDING FOR ONGOING
PROGRAMS- WHAT IS THE PAYMENTS
FINANCE WHAT IS THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCES PERSPECTIVE ON HOW DO
YOU ADDRESS. CONTINUING THAT
FUNDING INTO THE FUTURE ONCE
THE ONE TIME FUNDING IS UP IS
EXHAUSTED. CERTAINLY DEPENDING
UPON THE PARTICULAR ALLOCATION
THEIR EXTENDED- EXPENDITURE
ENCUMBRANCE STATES TO ALLOW.
THOSE FUNDS TO BE USED OVER A
MULTI YEAR PERIOD- AND
CERTAINLY AS YOU KNOW THE
BUDGET BELT IN FUTURE YEARS WE
WILL NOW CONTINUE TO OF REVIEW
AVAILABLE RESOURCE. OKAY-
CERTAINLY THERE AT THAT THAT'S
A CONCERN- I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
YOU QUITE THAT I GOT TO THAT HE
LANDED THAT ONE EITHER BUT I'M
JUST- IT CERTAINLY CONCERNED
THAT ONCE THE ONE TIME FUNDING
IS- IS GONE FOR THESE ONGOING
PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
LEFT- KIND OF STRUGGLING TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO NEXT I
AND THAT LEADS ME I GUESS SINCE
YOU-JUMPING TO S. B. ONE SIXTY
ONE- CERTAINLY THE SIGNIFICANT
ITEM THERE IS- WELFARE FUNDING.
SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THIS MEASURE TAKES THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION THAT WAS. IT
THAT IS WAS SUPPOSED TO BE AND
ARE IN THAT WAS. PROPOSED TO BE
AND- NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET AND
MAKES IT AVAILABLE FOR WILDFIRE
PREVENTION THIS YEAR SO WHAT
CRITERIA WILL BE USED TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THAT FUNDING
IS GOING TO BE EXPENDED.
ASSEMBLY JUST CLARIFY BECAUSE I
THINK I GOT SOME MORE CLEAR FOR
CLOSURE SO ACTUALLY DISTRICTS
SO- ON. THERE THERE WAS I THINK
CONFUSION ABOUT THE ONE BILLION
THAT WAS DONE IN AB ONE TWENTY
EIGHT. SO FOR OVER TWO YEARS SO
THE ONE BILLION OVER TWO YEARS
IS STILL. BEING DONE THE
DIFFERENCE IS WE ANTICIPATE
CONTINUING TO WORK ON A DEAL
BETWEEN NOW AND THE END OF
SESSION AND FOR THIS COMING
BUDGET YEAR. IN THAT DEAL WILL
BE BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED AND-
UNDERSTANDING WORD WORD BEEN
AND- BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION TO SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION- WITH THE IDEA
THAT THROUGH THE REMAINDER
WHAT. WE'RE GOING TO YEAR TOO
SO IT'S STILL A BILLION OVER
TWO YEARS WE'RE STILL WORKING
OUT THOSE DETAILS I THINK
THAT'S WHY. THEY ARE CONTINUING
TO BE A LOT OF QUESTIONS. I WAS
OBVIOUSLY MEMBERS HAVE YOU KNOW
FEEDBACK CONCERNS THOSE ARE
ISSUES THAT WE ARE CONTINUING
TO. DISCUSS SO FEEL FREE TO
KEEP TALKING TO US ABOUT THE
NUMBER OF THE TOUGHEST
INCORPORATE THAT INTO ROOMS
THANK ACTUALLY OKAY I MIGHT IF
I IF I COULD ASK MISTER CHAIR
CLARIFY- SAID THE- THERE'S
GONNA BE THE DISCUSSION IS
GOING TO THE RANGE IS GOING TO
BE. BETWEEN TWO FIFTY EIGHT AND
SEVEN FIFTY. FOUR UP FOR THE
NEXT TWO YEARS NO DOUBT FOR
NEXT YEAR FOR NEXT YEAR YEAH
OKAY FOR THIS FOR THIS BUDGET
YEAR THAT WE ARE. PASSING A
BUDGET. OKAY SO THIS BUDGET
YEAR THAT WE ALREADY ENTERED
OKAY SO THIS EXAM IS ONE TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT THAT THE TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY BUDGET
THERE'S GOING THERE'S
DISCUSSIONS ONGOING OF. A
BUMPING THAT. AMOUNT
APPROPRIATED TO SEVEN FIFTY
NINE. THE TEMPERATURE BIRDS
WOULD STILL BE A- FOR THE TWO
YEARS. SO DON'T GO CHRISTIAN.
YEAH COULD SOMEONE FROM THOMAS
FROM TRY THIS YEAR HELLO SORRY
I HAD THE WRONG OKAY THANK
THERE TO. HIMSELF AT WELL WHEN
I HIT THE BUT NOT THIS ONE-
OKAY SO THEY ANY TO THE TO FINE
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT THE SEX
THERE'S TWO MILLION. A TEACHER
FUNDING WE MAKES UP THE BALANCE
OF THE DOLLARS SO THAT'S PART
OF THAT THEY DO HERE IS AB ONE
TWENTY EIGHT WAS SORT OF A
TOTAL AMOUNT OF FUNDING AND NOW
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT GENERAL
FUND VERSES. GRF SO THAT'S
THAT'S PART OF WHY THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE SO COULD COULD YOU
JUST- THEN PROVIDE IN THIS THIS
FISCAL YEAR. HOW MUCH WILL BE.
DISCUSSED HOW MUCH IS BEING
DISCUSSED TO BE ALLOCATED IN
THIS FISCAL YEAR ADDED GENERAL
FUND AND HOW MUCH IS BEING
DISCUSSED AT A TEACHER AT. IF
YOU COULD. IF YOU COULD PROVIDE
THAT. SO INTHE IN ONE TWENTY
NINE THERE IS SOME TEACHER
EFFORTS AT THE TOP I HAD I
DON'T HAVE THE EXACT AMOUNT
THERE IS A LITTLE BIT IN. ONE
TWENTY ON ALREADY. HAS OTHERS
THE BALANCE OF THAT FOR THIS
FISCAL YEAR IT'S UP TO THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THIS FISCAL YEAR. AND THEN IN
ADDITION WORDS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A RANGE OF TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY. EIGHT MILLION TO SEVEN
OR FIFTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
OF GENERAL FUND. HOW WHICH
WOULD BE ON THE TABLE IN TERMS
OF ARCHITECTURE THAT WE JUST
DESIGNED IN THE BUDGET
AGREEMENT FOR DISCUSSION ABOUT.
HOW THAT MONEY SHOULD BE FUNDED
AND WHEN THAT MONEY SHOULD BE
SPENT IT BASED ON. HOW FAST OF
THE MONEY THAT WE'VE ALREADY
PUT OUT. WHICH MEMBER WE PUT UP
THE EARLY ACTION MONEY THAT WAS
ONLY. TOO HAPPY MONTHS AGO
THREE MONTHS AGO SO WE KIND OF
LOOKING AT THAT. IT'S A WE GET
BACK FROM SUMMER RECESS- AS- AS
YOU REQUESTED THERE'S- GOING TO
BE HEARING ON WILDFIRES WILL
GOING TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT
THAT. AND BE ABLE TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT THE EXPANSION LEVELS ARE
AND WHERE IT WILL BE
APPROPRIATE. TO PUT FUNDING AND
WHERE THE NEEDS ARE SO THAT THE
MONEY'S BEST USE BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A GREAT NEED.
FOR SURE. SO I PUTS THE BY BY
I'M GLAD THAT THAT THE
OVERSIGHT HEARING IS GOING TO
BE- THERE'S GONNA TAKE PLACE I
THINK WE'RE GONNA NEED THAT.
THAT TYPE OF TRANSPARENCY TO
KNOW- WHAT THE CAPACITY IS AND
WHAT'S BEING DONE. FOR SURE-
BUT I GUESS I'M JUST TRYING TO
WRAP MY HANDS AROUND THE FACT
THAT WE- HOPE. AS WE DISCUSS
THIS- THIS BILL. WHAT HOW MUCH
MONEY IS. IT SO YOU'RE SAYING
THAT IT'S UP TO SEVEN FIFTY
MILLION FOR THIS. FISCAL BUT
THIS THIS CURRENT BUDGET. SO
THIS IS JUST THE ARCHITECTURE
IN WHICH WE'VE SORT OF BUILT
THIS BUDGET PACKAGE IN TERMS OF
THE ASSUMPTIONS OVERALL AND SO
THAT WE WHEN WE DID BILL THAT
WE HAVE THESE THIS ASSUMPTION
ABOUT HOW MUCH MONEY WE WOULD
SPEND ON THIS WHICH WAS IN ONE
TWENTY EIGHT. AND THEN ONE
TWENTY NINE WAS SORT OF AN R.
FLEXION OF HOW MUCH WE THOUGHT
WOULD BE IN THIS FISCAL VERSUS
PEOPLE SO THIS IS TRYING TO
RESET THE CONVERSATION TO A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT HE
WANTS BEEN BILLION DOLLARS.
LET'S HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE TO SPEND
I GOTCHA I THINK I'M I THINK WE
MAY BE CONFUSING PEOPLE EVEN
MORE SO I UNDERSTAND THAT. IT'S
THE INTENT HERE IS TO YOU KNOW
THAT. THIS THIS ENTIRE CONTROL
SECTION IS ABOUT. FUTURE
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THE BUDGET.
IT'S NOT ACTUALLY. THE ACTUAL
PROPOSALS WE HAVE TO COME BACK.
AFTER THAT. AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABSOLUTE SO THEN
WILL. IN IN TERMS OF WHAT'S
BEING NEGOTIATED. NOW OR WHAT
WE WERE NEGOTIATING. THAT THAT
I CAN'T THAT AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES. IS UP TO SEVEN FIFTY
MILLION. THAT IS SET ASIDE
RIGHT NOW SO IS THAT RIGHT YEAH
OKAY- OKAY THAT THAT'S WHERE I
DIDN'T A PART OF WHAT WE'RE
DETERMINING PROBABLE CAUSE AND
THAT DETERMINATION. ACTUALLY
WHAT CAN BE SPENT RIGHT SO I
THINK IT'S ALSO TRYING TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND- THAT THAT'S
A KEY COMPONENT IS WHAT'S WHAT
REALISTICALLY COULD BE SPENT ON
ESTRADA. SAID THEN IF I COULD
FOLLOW UP ON ON THAT THAT- AT
THE NUMBERS AND IF THE IF THE
GOAL IS A BILLION DOLLARS. I'M
ASSUMING A GRAPHIC AND THAT IS
ASSUMING BOTH GENERAL FUND AND
EUROPE TOGETHER CORRECT- DOES
SO IF THE SEVEN FIFTY IS JUST
GENERAL FUND. DOES THAT MEAN
AND IN YOUR ATTIC ARE YOU
ADDING TWO HUNDRED MILLION. I
DID YEAR AFTER THAT HE GETS A
ONE BILLION. CORRECT AND IN
ADDITION THERE'S SOME G. DRAFT
THAT'S ALREADY IN AB ONE TWENTY
NINE THAT'S FOUR FIVE FIRES
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT THERE
WHICH UP GET OFF TOM HEADED OUT
FROM THE EXACT AMOUNT SO. IT'S
ROUGH ABC COMES I THINK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE BILLION
TOTAL FUNDS WHEN YOU WHEN YOU
HAVE THEM LOT- SO- IN GENERAL
THAT BUT THE IDEA AGAIN IS THAT
THAT'S WHAT THE ASSUMPTION IS
FOR THE ARCHITECTURE FOR THE
CONVERSATION BUT WE HAVE TO
COME BACK AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION I DON'T THINK
WE'RE NOT. REALLY GOING TO BE.
LIKE FOUNDED IN EXACTLY BY
THOSE NUMBERS WE HAVE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT MAKES
SENSE BASED ON THE HEARING THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE WE GET
BACK. ATTACHED SO. THAT I AM
I'M ASSUMING THEN THAT WILL.
FLOW I SHOULD ASSUME. SB ONE
TWENTY NINE IS NOT SIGNED INTO
LAW YET SO ARE WE ANTICIPATING
THAT THAT WILL BE SIGNED INTO
LAW. AND THEN WE'RE AMENDING
BETWEEN NINE. THE GOVERNOR HAS
WILL YOU BE AMENDED YOU BE WE
WOULD BE AMENDING AB ONE TWENTY
EIGHT. THE GOVERNOR HAS UNTIL
JULY TWELFTH TO SIGN OR VETO-
SB ONE TWENTY NINE. OKAY AND
THIS BILL AB ONE AB IN SB ONE
SIXTY ONE ENVISIONS THE
GOVERNOR SIGNING ONE TWENTY.
OKAY BECAUSE THIS DOG SO THEN
THIS. SB ONE SIXTY ONE. A MAN.
SB ONE THREE NINE. IS THAT
CORRECT BUT AS TO WHAT'S GOING
ON IS THE SOON TO BE OR COULD
BE SIGNED. AT ANY TIME BUT-
WE'RE ASSUMING. THAT IS IN LAW.
INDOLENT AS WE DISCUSSED THIS
YEAH. BUT THE- AS THE MEASURE
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY. IT THAT
THAT THE IDEA IS. OBVIOUSLY
WHAT ONCE WE- ARE ABLE TO AGREE
HAVE AN AGREEMENT THEN ALL THE
CREAM IT WOULD REPLACE THESE
ASSUMPTIONS OKAY SO THAT WOULD
BE. LATER THIS THAT WOULD
BUDGET JUNIOR JUNIOR JUNIOR
THAT WOULD BE THE BUDGET FOUR
POINT OH FIVE POINT OH MAYBE
OKAY FOR A COMPUTER. OKAY SO- I
APPRECIATE THAT CLARIFICATION
AND I THINK THAT'S THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT ONE- I THINK THAT. IS
THE GOAL THEN IS WITH DESIGNERS
AND ONE BILLION OVER THE NEXT
TWO YEARS. BUT WE'RE NOT WE
WANT TO FRONT LOAD AS MUCH
MONEY INTO THIS CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR- WITH THE IT WITH THE
INFORMATION THAT WE GET FROM
OVERSIGHT HEARING TO WHAT THE
CAPACITY IS. I WOULD REDEFINE
GOAL AS THE BUDGET AGREEMENT
SET ASIDE RESOURCES FOR BILLION
DOLLARS OVER TWO YEARS FOR
WILDFIRES AND SO IT'S A YOU
KNOW BASICALLY FOR CONVERSATION
WHEN WE GET BACK ON WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO THAT BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT IS NOT THE- END OF THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT THAT'S
JUST WHAT WE HAVE IN THIS
BUDGET AGREEMENT FOR JUNE AND
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE OKAY.
SO FOR THE PURPOSES OF THIS
CONVERSATION THEN WITH WITH- SB
ONE SIXTY ONE. IT IS IT IS- TWO
FIFTY EIGHT. PLUS THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION THAT WHAT WOULD
BE ACCESSIBLE THIS CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR. THE SO WE WOULD BE
WE WHAT WE'RE DEBATING AND WITH
THE WITH THE WITH THE POSSIBLE
WILDFIRE- PACKAGE BEING
DISCUSSED THAT THAT WOULD BE
ALLOCATING SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION FOR THIS. FISCAL YEAR.
GENERAL FUND CREDIT OFTEN
GENERAL FUND AND THEN AND THEN
WE WOULD HAVE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION. POTENTIALLY DISCUSSED
ENERGY HERE IF WE WERE GOING TO
ABIDE BY THE- BY THAT THE
OBJECTIVES OF SB NINE A ONE. IN
THE PAST IT JUST FOR ME TO
CLARIFY IS THAT APPROXIMATELY
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY SO I THINK
THE ACTUAL NUMBER SEVEN FORTY
EIGHT FOR LACK OF A BETTER THAN
FORTY CLASSIFICATION. OKAY SO I
THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR AT THAT
THAT. IS VERY HELPFUL- I THINK
FROM FROM MY PERSPECTIVE AND
MAYBE THIS NOW WITH THIS
CLARIFICATION IS INFORMATION.
MY QUESTION THAT FORMER FINANCE
IS. UNDERSTANDING OF THIS
NEGOTIATION THAT'S HAPPENING
FOR AT SEVEN FORTY MILLION-
WOOD THE ADMINISTRATION TO BE
AMENABLE TO ALLOWING IF THERE
IS A CAPACITY CHALLENGED FROM
CAL FIRE TO ALLOW- FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS GPAS
NONPROFITS TO BE ABLE TO
UPPLEMENT. THE WORK THAT CAL
FIRE MAY NOT HAVE CAPACITY TO
DO THAT PART OF THE
CONVERSATION. YEAH THIS IS
STEPHEN BENSON DEPARTMENT
FINANCE. YES THAT'S THAT'S- SO
IF YOU'RE CONSERVING BACK A
LITTLE BIT SO IF YOU RECALL THE
EARLY ACTION PACKAGE THAT WAS
THE FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SIX
MILLION THAT WAS APPROVED BACK
IN APRIL. WITH THAT PLAN AND IT
IS IT ALLOCATED SPECIFIC
AMOUNTS TO DEPARTMENTS AND
PROGRAMS. THAT TYPE OF
ALLOCATION IS WHAT IS YET TO BE
DONE. FOR THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
EIGHT MILLION THAT'S IN THE
BUDGET FRAMEWORK. AND IT WAS
JUST TALK ABOUT. SO WITHIN THAT
FRAMEWORK WELL I ASSUME WILL BE
CONSIDERING THE SAME PROGRAM
THE SAME DEPARTMENTS- WITHIN
THAT THERE ARE PORTIONS OF THAT
FUNDING THAT GO OUT IN TERMS OF
GRANTS TO ALL OF THOSE TYPES OF
GROUPS AND THEY'LL AND THEY
WILL BE DOING PROJECTS ARE
DOING PROJECTS NOW WITH THEIR
THE ACTION FUNDING IN IT AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE. PART OF A
CONVERSATION FOR FUNDING TO
FLOW TO THEM TO CONTINUE
PROJECTS SURE. I THINK MY ONLY.
OUR MAIN CONCERN IS THAT. WE'RE
IN THE THROES OF- OF- WILDFIRE
SEASON RIGHT NOW. SO IF THERE
IS. PROJECTS IF THERE ARE- FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND NONPROFIT
SECOND DO ADDITIONAL WORK NOW.
I WOULD HOPE THAT WE'RE NOT
WAITING TO ALLOCATE THE TWO
FIFTY EIGHT. WE WOULD BE
EXPANDING. THAT MONEY NOW TO DO
MORE WORK NOW. SO THE WAY THAT
THE BUDGET IS CURRENTLY
CRAFTED- ALL OF THIS FUNDING IS
IN CONTROL SECTION OR SECTION
NINETEEN POINT FIVE FIVE. AND
WE ARE NOT ABLE TO SEND ANY
MONEY THAT MANY OF THAT MONEY
OUT UNTIL FUTURE LEGISLATION-
ADOPTS AN ALLOCATION OF THAT
ONE OKAY SO THAT'S ONLY
INCUMBENT UPON US FOR SURE SO I
HAVE THE PHONE YOU'RE A BUT
YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT THE FIVE
THIRTY SIX THAT WAS THAN IT
REALLY ACTION ALL OF THAT HAS
BEEN EXPENDED. IT I DON'T HAVE
AN EXACT ACCOUNTING FOR HOW
MUCH IS OUT THE DOOR RIGHT NOW
BUT YES THAT IS IN THE ACTIVE-
ACTIVELY GOING OUT THE DOOR.
AND I THINK IN SOME CASES
DEPARTMENTS HAVE FULLY
ALLOCATED IN THE WARD SOME OF
IT OTHERS PROBABLY ARE STILL IN
THE PROCESS. SO WITH THE- THE
TWO FIFTY EIGHT THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING AND THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
AT A GENERAL FUND- IS THE
ADMINISTRATION OPEN TO DOING
SOME SECRET FORMER STREAM. AT
ATTACHING THAT TO IT TOO TO
ALLOW MORE THAT MONEY TO. TO GO
FURTHER. AND TO DO MORE
PROJECTS. SO THE WAY THAT WE
ARE ENVISIONING IT RIGHT NOW IS
ONCE AN ALLOCATION PLAN IS THIS
IS A GREEN TO AND- ENACTED
THROUGH THE FUTURE LEGISLATION
THAT'S ANTICIPATED. THEN WHAT
WE WOULD DO IS AS- AS
DEPARTMENTS WORK THROUGH THEIR
PORTION OF THE TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION. AND
THEY'RE READY TO ACCESS THEIR
PORTION OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION WE WOULD START MAKING
THAT FIVE THAT THOSE PORTIONS
AVAILABLE TO THOSE DEPARTMENTS.
WE JUST EXPECT WE EXPECTED
THAT- THE RATE THROUGH WHICH-
SOME PORTIONS OF THAT ARE USED
WILL DIFFER FROM DEPARTMENT TO
DEPARTMENT FROM PROGRAM TO
PROGRAM. OKAY I THINK THAT MY
MAIN POINT IS THAT. WE WANT TO
SUPPLEMENT AND COMPLEMENT WHAT
CALIFORNIA'S DOING CERTAINLY
THERE'S A LOT ON THEIR PLATE.
AND I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
CAPACITY CHALLENGES. I THINK
THAT- FOR US AS A LEAD TO THE
BODY. I AM FOR THOSE TO
REPRESENT- FIRE REGIONS- ARE
FIRE PRONE REGIONS WE HAVE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT. ARE WILLING
TO DO THE WORK NOW THAT HAVE
THEY HAVE EXTRA CAPACITY. SO WE
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE. THAT THOSE
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS BE
MORE ROBUST- TO ALLOW MORE WORK
MORE ACRES TO BE TREATED MORE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT TO BE
DONE. I THINK THAT'S WHAT I'M
ENCOURAGING- AND MBANK KIND OF
IMPLORING AND PLEADING FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO DO. IS TO
ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN- AND OF
COURSE- YOU KNOW THERE ARE
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATIONS
IRONICALLY IN- THE EDUCATION-
TRAILER BILL THAT WE DISCUSSED
SO. WHY NOT. PUSH FOR
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION- FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION. IT RIGHT
NOW IN IN IN THIS IN THIS
CURRENT BUT THE SCHOOL YEAR OR
IN THE ND IN THIS TRAILER
BILLS WAS THAT IT OR IS THAT
PART OF THE DISCUSSION IN THE-
YEAH AND IN THE WHILE FIRED
NEGOTIATIONS. IS TO ACTUALLY
PUT IN A CONTINUES
APPROPRIATIONS. SINCE THE TWO
THINGS I'LL TAKE UP THERE SO
WHAT ONE OF THE PILLARS TO THE
WILDFIRE ACTION PLAN THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS WERE
REBELS AROUND IS ACTUALLY IS A
REGIONAL COLLABORATIONS TO
BUILD AND REGIONAL SCALE
WILDFIRE TREATMENT OF LANDS.
AND SO THAT IS A MAJOR
COMPONENT WE'RE STILL TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH HERE AND ANY EARLY
ACTION AND A LOT OF WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT DOING WITH THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. IS GETTING
THAT INTO SO DEPARTMENT
CONSERVATION RUNS REGIONAL-
PROGRAM THAT HELPS TO GET
PROJECTS SET UP ON A REGIONAL
SCALE. FUNDING WENT OUT TO
CONSERVANCY SO THEY COULD WORK
ON A REGIONAL SCALE PROJECTS
THAT'S ALL PART OF- THE WELFARE
ACTION PLANS ALL PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION THE ALLOCATIONS
THAT WE'LL BE DISCUSSING.
MATTERS WITH THE STRONG PILLARS
OF THE ACTUAL PLAN IN TERMS OF
THE CONTINUOUS PREPARATION
QUESTION THAT'S MORE OF A
BUDGET FRAMEWORK BUDGET
ARCHITECTURE QUESTION- I SITE
YOU KNOW. ALL I CAN REALLY SAY
ON THAT IS WHEN THE BUDGET WAS
DISCUSSED AND NEGOTIATED- THE
INDIANS FRIENDMARK THE
STRUCTURE THAT WE LANDED ON.
WEST TWO HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
MILLION WITH FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION THAT'S IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE. AND THIS LANGUAGE IS TO
ALLOW US TO ALLOCATE THAT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. IF
PROJECTS MOVE AT A PACE THAT
DEMONSTRATE. THE NEED TO HAVE
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING AVAIL
NOW IS. OKAY WELL I WANT TO BE
THE POINT HAD OUR- DISK ROBUST
DISCUSS I THINK THAT. I THINK
WHAT YOU'VE JUST ENDED NO WHAT
YOU SAID. I THINK IS. ACTUALLY
WHAT WE ARE ASKING FOR A WAY A
FOR A ALL OF US ALL OF US IN
WELL BY PRONE AREAS ARE AT. FOR
A THAT WE WANT MORE CAPACITY WE
WANT MORE REGIONAL PARTNERSHIPS
WE WANT MORE MONEY AND WE WANT
MORE CONTINUOUS PREPARATION.
AND WE NEED WE NEED TO
STREAMLINING TO DO SO BECAUSE
WE ARE SEEING FIRES IN OUR
REGION RIGHT NOW I MEAN THEY'VE
BEEN TO FIRES. IN THE KERN
COUNTY REGION- AND THEN OF
COURSE- OF ELEVEN OR SO FIRES I
THINK TO A STATEWIDE SO- YOU
KNOW WE'VE WE ARE SEEING WE ARE
DEBATING. WE'RE REVIEWING RIGHT
NOW CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATIONS.
FOR OTHER TRAILER BILLS. MY
THAT'S HAPPENED SO THE- YOU CAN
SAY THAT WE CAN'T DO IT
CONTINUES APPROPRIATIONS
BECAUSE- UNDER SB ONE THIRTY.
THERE ARE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATIONS IN THERE. FOR
IMPORTANT THINGS- CERTAINLY IN
THE EDUCATION SPACE. WHAT WE'RE
ARGUING- IS THAT WILDFIRE
PREVENTION IS ACTUALLY
IMPORTANT TO AND SO WE NEED TO
DO IS A PREPARATIONS FOR THAT
AS WELL SO WITH THAT THEY CAN
SECURE FOR ADOPTION. THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER. THANK YOU MISTER
FLIPS YOU HEAR ME. OKAY THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS IS FOR A
BILL HOUSE AFFECT THE ABILITY
OF YOU SEE HOSPITALS TO
MODERNIZE OR MAKE SEISMIC
RETROFITS TO PREPARE FOR THE
NEXT PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS.
CHRIS FERGUSON WITH FINANCE- I
BELIEVE THAT THE- TRAILER BILL
DOESN'T SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO
THAT ASPECT. THAT SAID HE'S HE
GENERALLY USES REVENUE BONDS TO
SUPPORT THESE TYPES OF
ACTIVITIES AND OR YOU KNOW
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT THEY MAY BE
ELIGIBLE TO PARTICIPATE AND- ON
THE HEALTH SIDE. SO HOW IS THIS
DIFFERENT FROM SB EIGHT TWENTY
WHICH WAS SIGNED THE LAW LAST
YEAR REQUIRES YOU SEE TO
CERTIFY ANNUALLY TO DEAL LEFT.
THAT BUILDINGS BUILT TO THE
STATE FOR A CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROCESS- BEING OPERATED AND
MAINTAINED BY YOU SEE EMPLOYEES.
APOLOGIES I MISUNDERSTOOD YOUR-
COMMENT SO CERTAINLY THIS BILL
MAKES- BURKE PROPOSES CHANGES
TO THAT PROCESS- BUT YOU KNOW
WE DON'T HAVE I WOULD SAY. THAT
YOU KNOW THE CHANGES WERE
DESIGNED TO CAPTURE ADDITIONAL
FACILITIES- CERTAINLY THERE ARE
SOME ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES PLACED IN THE
BILL- BUT I WOULD JUST LIMIT MY
COMMENTS IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT THAT. LANGUAGE DOES
AS OPPOSED TO- YOU KNOW ANY
PARTICULAR- COMMENTS FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION ON OF THE TERM
OF THAT. LINE MISTER PERFECT
QUESTIONS WELL OKAY IF YOU
ANSWERED THANK YOU. YEAH MARC
MARTIN WITH THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE- SO THE LANGUAGE IN
QUESTION I THINK YOU'RE
REFERENCING LAST YEAR'S
CHRISTIAN IT YES LANGUAGE SO
THAT ADDED A CERTIFICATION
PROCESS FOR YOU SEE. TO CERTIFY
THAT THEY WERE NOT. OUTSOURCING
WORKERS THE LANGUAGE IN
QUESTION NOW FURTHER DEFINES
THAT CERTIFICATION PROCESS. SO
IT SORT OF BUILDS ON LAST
YEAR'S LINE OKAY IN THE IN THE
REASON THE REASON I BUILT ON
LAST YEAR'S IS BECAUSE THAT THE
UNIVERSITY APPEARS TO HAVE
IGNORED LAST YEAR'S LAST YEAR'S
LANGUAGE OKAY SO THIS IS A
FOLLOW UP HELLO THIS LANGUAGE
DIFFERENT FROM A POLICY
PROHIBITING CONTRACTING WORK
APPROVED BY THE UC RAGE
REGENTS- REASONS POLICY FIFTY
FOUR OH TWO. WELL I THINK THE-
THE LANGUAGE STRENGTHENS THE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS. THAT YOU
SEE DIDN'T DO THIS YEAR THAT WE
WHAT THEY WERE WE WERE SUPPOSED
TO RECEIVE A REPORT ON FEBRUARY
FIRST WE RECEIVED A REPORT ON
JUNE ELEVENTH WHICH DID SHOW
THIRTY TWO EXAMPLES OF YOU SEE
OUTSOURCING WORK. SO THIS
LANGUAGE IS A MORE- JUST MORE
DETAILED PROCESS FOR THEM TO
CERTIFY THAT THEY ARE NOT
VIOLATING THE REGION'S POLICY.
AND THE STATE LAW THAT ALREADY-
REQUIRES YOU SEE TO USE ITS OWN
WORKFORCE IN STATE FUNDED
BUILDING. THANK YOU FOR. MISS
FRAZIER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I JUST WANTED TO KIND OF-
INCLUDE ONE OF THE
POSSIBILITIES POSSIBLY. IS MR
WELL FUNDED TALKED ABOUT WHEN
YOU TALK ABOUT- ACCESSING OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OF WILDFIRE
PREVENTION OR SUPPRESSION- WHY
ARE WE TALKING TO THE UTILITIES
WHO ALREADY ARE ENGAGED. INTO
THE AREAS- THAT OF
RESPONSIBILITY THEY ALREADY
HAVE A MOMENTUM IF THEY COULD
LEVERAGE STATE DOLLARS ALSO FOR
THEIR PROGRAMS. ALSO SOME OF
THE LARGER TIMBER COMPANIES WHO.
WHO HAVE A VESTED INTEREST IN
TO BEING- PROACTIVE ON THIS.
FRONT TOO SO THE ONLY FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS BUT ALSO OTHER
ENTITIES THAT ARE ALREADY
ENGAGED IN THIS PROCESS THAT
MIGHT BE ABLE TO LEVERAGE THEIR
RESOURCES AND GET A GREATER
GAME WITH INVESTMENT FROM THE
STATE. I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE REALLY DO NEED TO LOOK
AT. THE OTHER THING IS- JUST ON
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION FRONT- NO
SURPRISE HERE LET ME ASK YOU
THESE QUESTIONS- WHAT ARE WE-
WHAT IS DETERMINING THIS
AMOUNTS THAT I SEIZE UP. IN THE
SEPARATE COLUMNS- THAT WE WILL
BE ABLE TO HAVE SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOMES. FOR THE STUDENTS THAT
DID ACTUALLY REGRESS FROM NOT
BEING ABLE TO DISTANCE LEARN.
AND YOU KNOW THE WIND INTO A
COMPLETE KIND OF A THE CYCLE
BEHAVIORAL ISSUES HOW ARE WE
GOING TO ASSESS. EXCESS ON THIS
NUMBER ONE AND SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT I DID NOTICE PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC. WHEN I DID GO
INTO SOME OF THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION CLASSES WAS THERE WAS
A KIND OF A OF. A BUNDLING OF
STUDENTS. OF FROM LIKE MAYBE K.
TWO FOUR. AND SO. THEY WERE
GETTING A KIND OF AN ECONOMY OF
SCALE WITH HER PROFESSIONALS
AND OR THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER WERE. A LOT OF THE KIDS
THROUGH THEIR ASSESSMENTS
NEEDED MORE INDIVIDUALIZED IEP
KIND OF YOU KNOW OF. TREATMENT
NOT TREATMENT BUT YOU KNOW
INSTRUCTION. AND SO. YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHERE
WE'VE BEEN NOW THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC AND THEN THERE'S
REGRESSION AND THEN IF THEY'RE
THAT SAME PATTERN OF BUNDLING
STUDENTS GOES FORWARD. HOW DO
WE- YOU KNOW. HOW DO WE ADVANCE
HOW DO WE HOW DO WE MOVE
FORWARD SO. I WAS HOPING THAT
WE CAN LOOK AT THAT AND
CONCENTRATE BECAUSE AGAIN- YOU
KNOW IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT WE
PROVIDE SUCCESS FOR THESE
STUDENTS ALSO- AND THE MORE
THAT WE TIME IT WE INVEST THAT
THE BETTER OUTCOMES WE HALF.
AND SO I'M JUST LOOKING FORWARD
TO YOU KNOW DISCUSSION ON THAT
TOO BUT I DO APPRECIATE. THE
RECOGNITION THAT YOU KNOW THERE
WAS A DESPERATE NEED FOR HELP
IN THIS ARENA AND CRESCENTA I
DO UNDERSTAND YOUR ENGAGEMENT
AND I APPRECIATE IT. THANK
MISCONDUCT. OKAY YEAH I HAVE A
FEW OBVIOUSLY GOT THREE THREE
PRETTY BIG TRAILER BILLS HERE-
BUT I'LL START WITH THE
WILDFIRES DISCUSSION- I HEARD A
LOT OF THINGS IN THERE THAT I
JUST DON'T THINK YOU'RE- RIGHT
ACCURATE- FIRST OF ALL. EARLY
ACTION FUNDING THAT WE PASSED
EARLIER THIS YEAR A BIG CHUNK
OF THAT MONEY PAID FOR MONEY WE
WERE SUPPOSED TO EXPAND LAST
YEAR. OKAY SO THAT'S JUST DOING
WHAT YOU WERE WHAT YOU DIDN'T
DO. LAST YEAR AND PART OF WHAT
THEY'RE TELLING YOU THE BACKLOG
IS BECAUSE WE DIDN'T DO THAT
LAST YEAR YOUR SPENDING THAT
MONEY THIS YEAR THAT YOU SHOULD
HAVE DONE LAST YEAR. AND WHY
DID WE DO LAST YEAR LET'S TALK
ABOUT THAT. BECAUSE GIGI R. F.
CAP AND TRADE DID NOT PRODUCE
ENOUGH REVENUE. OR THE
ANTICIPATED REVENUE THAT WE-
THAT WE THOUGHT IT WOULD. IN
OUR RESPONSE OR AT LEAST THE A
MINUTE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
RESPONSE WAS LET'S NOT BACK
FILL THAT WOULD GENERAL FUND
MONEY. LET'S NOT MAKE WILD FIRE
PREVENTION A PRIORITY. THE
MONEY'S NOT THERE FROM GIGI R.
F. SO WE'RE NOT GOING TO SPEND
IT. THAT WAS A BIG MISTAKE AND
A PROBLEM. AND WE SHOULD BE ALL
ABOUT REMEDY IN NOW TO MAKING
SURE THAT WE MAKE THIS RIGHT
THAT THIS WE SHOULD NOT TO
FIGHT EVERY YEAR ABOUT. PUTTING
MONEY INTO WILDFIRE PREVENTION
IT SHOULD BE AUTOMATIC LIKE
PROP NINETY EIGHT. SHOULD BE. I
MEAN AFTER THESE FIVE YEARS THE
FIRES. UP AND DOWN THE STATE'S
SMOKE FILLING ORDER. IBM CARBON
EMISSIONS GOALS JUST BLOWN OUT
OF THE WATER WE'RE NOT GOING TO
MAKE THAT AN AUTOMATIC PRIORITY
EVERY YEAR THAT'S THE PROBLEM
OKAY. SO EARLY ACTION MONEY
DON'T TALK TO YOU ABOUT THAT
THAT'S WHAT YOU DID THAT'S WHAT
HE'S MAKING UP FOR WHAT YOU
DIDN'T DO. OKAY NOW LET'S TALK
ABOUT THIS YEAR AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IT BEING A
BILLION DOLLARS IS ONLY A
BILLION DOLLARS IF YOU'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO SPEND THE
MONEY AND MAKE SURE IT'S
ALLOCATED TO PROGRAMS AND GET
OUT THERE. THAT'S NOT WHAT
WE'RE DOING IN THIS BUDGET IS
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S WHAT IT IS. NOW
IN THIS NEW TRAILER BILL. YOU
KNOW THE GOVERNOR I DON'T KNOW
IF THOSE POLITICAL PRESSURE. OR
OTHERWISE WROTE US ALL LETTERS.
LAST WEEK RIGHT AFTER WAS
CALLED OUT THAT HE HASN'T BEEN
DOING WE HAVEN'T BEEN DOING THE
ACREAGE THAT HE SAID WE WERE
DOING THAT WE DIDN'T SPEND THE
MONEY LAST YEAR THAT THERE'S
ACTUALLY CUTS TO WILDFIRE
PREVENTION SO NOW HE SENDS US A
LETTER AND SAYS OKAY GUYS YEAH
AND ANOTHER FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION- THEY WERE DEFINITELY
GOING TO SPEND. NO GIVE ME
ANOTHER FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
THAT WILL ACCESS IF WE USE IF
WE SAY THAT WE NEED. THAT'S
WHAT THIS LANGUAGE SAYS SOME
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION NOT
NOTHING IS GOING TO ACTUALLY
GET SPEND GET OUT THERE AND SEE
THAT'S THE KIND OF THING THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO PRESENT- TO ME
AS DUPLICITOUS. IT IS DECEPTIVE
I THINK YOU JUST WE ARE WE JUST
SPENT FIFTEEN MINUTES
CLARIFYING WITH MR FONG WHAT
THAT MAN YEAH AND I'M GONNA RE
CLARIFY IT. I'M IN THE G.
CLARIFIED BECAUSE DO NOT
UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE THESE
ARE THE FACTS. THIS EXTRA FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION IS NOT
NECESSARILY GOING OUT THERE AT
ALL IT'S ONLY IF THIS
ADMINISTRATION CALLS FOR. IT'S
AGAIN RIGHT IT'S A- PLACEHOLDER
UNTIL WE CAN. CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS. TO FINALIZE THE
ACTUAL AMOUNT I DON'T KNOW WE
NEED TO DECIDE. WHAT YOU WANT
SO IF YOU WANT TO BE PART OF
THOSE DISCUSSIONS YOU'RE
WELCOME TO IF YOU WANT TO.
ADVANCE IT MR CHAIRMAN THAT'S
NOT FAIR I HAVE I HAVE SECOND
YOUR YOUR YOUR COMMENTS ARE
UNFAIR EITHER AT THE TIME
SAYING THEY AREN'T. GOING TO WE
JUST. NO THEY'RE NOT I'M NOT
GONNA LET PEOPLE LIE TO THE
PEOPLE WE'RE WE'RE NOT REALLY
BEING DONE. I'M NOT GONNA LET
THAT HAPPEN TODAY NO. AND SO
ALL I'M SAYING IS I WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT WHAT I'M SAYING IS
IF YOU IF YOU WANNA BE PART OF
THE PROCESS YOU WANT TO. WORK
AND BE PART OF IT THAT'S GREAT.
IF YOU DON'T WANT P. GO AHEAD
CONTINUE ON. OKAY I WANT TO BE
PART OF THE PROCESS AND SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THIS YEAR. I
INTRODUCED A BILL. THEY WOULD
HAVE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION FOR FIVE YEARS
AND A SEQUEL EXEMPTION WHICH IS
THE OTHER THING THAT CAL. WHY
WE HAVE A BACKLOG. TOM PORTER
TOLD YOU ON THE ARTICLE. WE
HAVE A BACKLOG BECAUSE WE NEED
SEEK REFORM WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO MOVE MORE PROJECTS. IT'S NOT
AS EASY AS WAVING A MAGIC WAND
TO GO DO THESE PROJECTS YOU GOT
TO GO THROUGH THIS BURDENSOME
PROCESS HE SAID THAT. PUBLICLY
IN THE PAPER. WE SHOULD BE
PAYING ATTENTION THAT IS OUR C.
CORE FORM IN THIS BUDGET
TRAILER BILL I DON'T KNOW WE'RE
CHANGING POLICY THAT YOU SEE.
WE CAN'T BE BOTHERED TO DO A
SEQUEL EXEMPTION IN THIS
TRAILER BILL THAT'S THE OTHER
PROBLEM. SO I'VE BEEN A PART OF
THIS PROCESS AND I'VE SENT YOU
LETTERS WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS.
I'VE CONTINUALLY SO WHAT I
THINK NEEDS TO BE DONE. ON THIS
ISSUE. I'M SORRY JUST IT'S JUST
THAT IT'S NOT GETTING DONE. AND
WE KEEP ACTING LIKE IT IS WE
DIDN'T SPEND THE MONEY LAST
YEAR THAT'S TRUE. WE MADE UP
FOR EARLY ACTION THAT'S TRUE.
AND NOW WE GOT TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY EIGHT MILLION THAT IS
DEFINITELY CONFIRMED. FOR THIS
BUDGET YEAR. AND WHAT AND I
DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT WE NEED
TO NEGOTIATE ABOUT WHAT WE NEED
TO NEGOTIATE MORE ABOUT IT'S
EITHER A PRIORITY IS NOT. PUT
IT IN THE BUDGET. JUST PUT IT
IF IT'S FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
GREAT PUT IT IN THERE. DON'T
SAY IS DEPENDENT ON WHETHER OR
NOT THE SAME ADMINISTRATION WHO
HASN'T BEEN DOING THE WORK. AND
WHO PREVIOUSLY SAID- WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH CAPACITY. WE'RE
GOING TO RELY ON THEM TO ASK
FOR THE MONEY LATER IN THE YEAR
THAT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE GOOD
ACCOUNTABILITY TO ME. AND THAT
IS WHY I THINK WE NEED
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION. THAT
ENSURES THIS MONEY'S GONNA GET
SPENT AND WE NEED TO REMOVE THE
BARRIERS TO CAPACITY. ONE OF
THE BIGGEST ONES A SEQUEL. AND
I'M GONNA CONTINUE TO BE PART
OF THE PROCESS BECAUSE I'M
GONNA BRING AN AMENDMENT AGAIN.
AND ASK YOU ALL TO VOTE FOR IT.
TO MAKE THE CHANGE THAT WE ALL
KNOW NEEDS TO BE DONE. THAT'S
THE END OF THE WILDFIRE
DISCUSSION THAT BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE REALLY AFTER TODAY.
I'M NOT GONNA GO ASK A QUESTION
SO I CAN HEAR MORE OBFUSCATION.
FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. NOW
MOVING INTO OUR HIGHER ED. SB
ONE THIRTY TWO. THE PROBLEM
HERE AS HAS BEEN POINTED OUT BY
THIS QUESTION IS WE'RE TRYING.
I THOUGHT WE ALL BELIEVE IN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING. I
THOUGHT WE BELIEVED IN THAT WE
BELIEVE IN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. BECAUSE IF WE DO
THEN WHY ARE WE TRYING TO IN
THIS BUDGET TRAILER BILL. MESS
WITH THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
BETWEEN THE US BETWEEN THE UC
AND ASKED ME THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE BECAUSE
YOU'RE LEVERAGING UP CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS THAT NEED TO
GET DONE. NOW WE ALL KNOW NEED
TO BE DONE AT OUR AT OUR UC'S.
AND LEVERAGING THEM INSANE
UNLESS YOU REALLY MEET THE
DEMANDS THAT'S GOING ON IN THIS
THERE'S ALREADY A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT WITH ASK
ME THERE'S ALREADY A POLICY.
THAT SAYS THEY CAN'T DO. THEY
CAN'T CONTRACT OUT. FOR THESE
OTHER SERVICES. AND WE'RE
ENTERING INTO IT INSTEAD OF
ALLOWING THAT COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING TO CONTINUE AND THE
AND THE CONTRACT IS ALREADY IN
PLACE TO CONTINUE. AND MORE
DANGEROUSLY HOLDING UP PROJECTS
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO BE DONE YEAH
YOU SEE. TO THE TUNE OF SEVEN
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS. AN
ACTIVE PROJECTS THAT NEED TO
GET BILL. THEY'RE GONNA PUT
ALSO BY THE WAY THEY'RE GOING
TO PUT PEOPLE TO WORK. DOING
THOSE MUCH NEEDED PROJECTS. AND
BE GOOD FOR THE ECONOMY AND BE
A GOOD FOR THOSE WORKERS WHY
ARE WE DOING THIS I MEAN THIS
BILL I GUESS IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE HEARD TOMORROW I HOPE IT
DOESN'T GET HURT AT ALL. IS
THIS IS EVERYTHING THAT'S WRONG
I MEAN IF YOU IF WE REALLY
GOING TO SAY I BELIEVE IN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING YOU
SHOULD NOT SUPPORT THIS BILL.
YOU'RE TRYING TO INTERFERE WITH
THE PROCESS AND YOU'RE HOLDING
UP MUCH NEEDED PROJECTS. IN
ORDER TO DO THAT IT'S NOT. IT'S
DEFINITELY NOT SOMETHING SHOULD
BE DONE IN A BUDGET TRAILER
BILL. AT THE VERY LEAST.
EDUCATION BUDGET TRAILER YOU
KNOW I I'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS
HAVE BEEN ON THE BUDGET SUB I
THINK WE DID A LOT OF GOOD WORK
THIS YEAR I AM CONCERNED- MY
SOME OF THESE LAST YOU KNOW
WHAT I WOULD CALL MORE LAST
MINUTE CHANGES- THE FOCUS ON
CONCENTRATION GRANTS AND SO
JUST HAVING SUPPLEMENTAL
FUNDING AND THAT'S A QUESTION I
HAVE I THOUGHT WE WERE ON THAT
TRACK OF JUST HAVING
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING ACROSS THE
BOARD FOR ALL SCHOOLS. INSTEAD
OF JUST FOCUSING ON-
CONCENTRATION GRANTS. PLEASE
COULD WE SPEAK TO THAT. WOULD
YOU LIKE US WOULD YOU LIKE L.
L. OR YEAH I KNOW IT'S- EITHER
ONE YEAH LET'S LET'S START WITH
DAILY- THE LOCAL FINANCE. I
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS SO THAT WAS- ISSUE WHEN
THEY WERE VISION HAD PROPOSED-
AN INCREASE IN THE
CONCENTRATION BROWN'S. OF
FUNDING- THE LEGISLATIVE-
BUDGET THAT ENDED UP DEAD A FEW
WEEKS AGO HAD I KEPT THE SAME
TOTAL AMOUNT OF FUNDING BUT
ALLOCATED THAT BASEDON-
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANTS AND THE
FINAL- AT THAT THE PACKAGE
BEFORE YOU- I THINK IT IS BACK
MORE TO. THE NAY REVISION- BUT
IN COMPOSED AND I'M A LOOK AT A
PRIVATE FINANCE SPEAKING ABOUT
THE THEIR- THINKING BEHIND THAT
PROPOSAL. CHRIS FERGUSON AGAIN
WITH FINANCE- YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE CERTAINLY UP FOCUSED ON-
YOU KNOW THE SCHOOLS THAT ARE
LIKELY TO HAVE THE GREATEST
NEEDS- AS SUCH YOU KNOW THAT'S
WHY WE FOCUSED ON- THE
CONCENTRATION GRADIENT. YEAH
BUT THE PROBLEM WITH THAT IS.
THERE ARE MANY SCHOOLS ARE I
MEAN LOOK SCHOOLS- EVERY SCHOOL
IN THIS STATE HAS KIDS IN IT
THAT IT THAT MEET THE CRITERIA
OF LOW INCOME- FOSTER CARE OR
HAVE- THE THAT MEET THAT
CRITERIA THE FOCUSING JUST ON
THOSE WHO REACH A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE THRESHOLD OF THOSE
KIDS IGNORES ALL THE OTHER KIDS
WHO MIGHT BE IN THE SCHOOLS TO.
AND THESE OTHER SCHOOLS BUT
THEY JUST DON'T MEET THE 55% OR
I GUESS IT'S 65% NOW-
CONCENTRATION GRANT FORMULA
RIGHT I MEAN. HAVING ALL KIDS
SUFFERED AND CERTAINLY KIDS AND
NOT IN THAT CATEGORY- YOU KNOW
LOW INCOME- ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS AND FOSTER CARE
STUDENTS ARE IN EVERY SCHOOL.
SO ARE YOU SHORT CHANGING THEM
IF YOU ONLY FOCUS ON
CONCENTRATION GRANTS- SCHOOLS.
NO I THINK YOU KNOW FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WE'RE FOCUSING ON
THOSE LEDS WITH THE HIGHEST
CONCENTRATION OF YOU KNOW LOW
INCOME STUDENTS ENGLISH
LANGUAGE. LEARNERS AND FOSTER
YOUTH THEY THINK THAT THAT'S
BEEN YOU KNOW OUR FOCUS. I'M
HOWEVER BUDGET STAFFER REQUIRE
FURNISHINGS GUARANTEE ONE FOR
FRESH. SURE I WOULD I WOULD
JUST REITERATE- WHAT THE ANY BY
THE WAY SORRY AARON GABLE
SOMETHING BUDGET STAFF- WHAT
THE HELL BE ELLIE- WHAT CANCER
DEBT- THIS IS THE MAY REVISED
PROPOSAL BUT IN ADDITION TO THE
CONCENTRATION GRANT BEING
INCREASED FOR LCF THAT WE DID
DO ALSO THE BASING CREASED
OVERALL OF OVER 5% INCREASED
ALL ELSE YET BACK WHICH IS.
IMPACT SUPPLEMENTAL
CONCENTRATION GRANTS WE- HAD
OVER A HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION INCREASES
THAT WERE NOT PART OF THE ME
REVISED THE HELPS TO SOFTEN THE
INCREASE THE CONCENTRATION
GRANT VERSUS OTHER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THEN FINALLY ARE
ON FINAL EXPANDED LEARNING
PACKAGE INCREASES BOTH
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
GRANDPARENTS ACROSS THE BOARD
SO WE WERE LOOKING AT THE
PACKAGE AS A WHOLE. OKAY SO
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANTS TO GET
INCREASED. IS THAT RIGHT AND.
YESTERDAY OUT THERE BEING
INCREASED AS A AS A SHARE OF
THE BASE OF LCF FAST AND THEN
THE- FOR THE EXPANDED LEARNING
PROGRAMS THAT THERE'S GOING TO
BE AMY ADAMS HELLO FOR FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS I BELIEVE HER
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANT ARE
UNDUPLICATED STUDENTS FOR
EXPANDED LEARNING PURPOSES SO
THOSE WERE ON DIFFERENT
FORMULAS. OKAY AND THEN THE
OTHER CONCERN IS THAT THIS IS
THE SECOND YEAR IN A ROW THAT
WE HAVE NOT PUBLISHED A
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD- TO
ME THIS LEAVES ELEAZAR WHO ARE
FAILING THEIR STUDENTS IN A
HOLDING PATTERN. WITHOUT
NECESSARILY INTERVENTIONS AND
SUPPORT. AND LEAVE STATE POLICY
MAKERS LIKE US IN THE POSITION
OF ALLOCATING BILLIONS OF
LEARNING RECOVERY. FUNDING
BASED ON DEMOGRAPHIC
ASSUMPTIONS AS OPPOSED TO.
ACTUAL STUDENT INCOMES I MEAN
BASICALLY ACCOUNTABILITY RIGHT
WE NEED TO HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND WAY MORE MONEY GOING OUT
THERE THAN EVER BEFORE THAT'S
GREAT. BUT THERE STILL NEEDS TO
BE ACCOUNTABILITY THAT WE'RE
REACHING. STUDENT OUT THE
OUTCOMES AND METRICS THAT WE
WANT FOR OUR STUDENTS YOU KNOW
AND AT NOWSM THAT'S GOING TO BE
MORE IMPORTANT EVER. BECAUSE OF
WHAT WE'VE BEEN THROUGH AND WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN LEARNING
LOSS THAT THAT HAS OCCURRED.
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE L. E. AS THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE. DOING THEIR JOB
TO GET IT DONE. BY STUDENTS
AND- I AM CONCERNED ABOUT THE
LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY- IN HERE
THERE'S ACCOUNTABILITY ON
INDEPENDENT STUDY AT I
APPRECIATE THAT I MEAN. HELPING
TO ENSURE THERE'S GOING TO BE
IN PERSON. LEARNING BUT
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR MAKING SURE
THAT WERE. ME MATTRESS I THINK
IS EQUALLY IMPORTANT- AND
LASTLY I MEAN THIS IS ANOTHER
ONE YOU WANT- FINANCES TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE- AS MORE OF
A STATEMENT I GUESS SO AS
OPPOSED TO A QUESTION WELL HOW
ABOUT CAN I CAN BECAUSE I MEAN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO COULD COULD
TARGET DEPARTMENT FINANCE TALK
ABOUT WHITE THE DASHBOARD HAS
BEEN PUT ON. CERTAINLY I THINK
THAT PART OF THE RATIONALE FOR-
YOU KNOW THAT. THE DELAY ON THE
DASHBOARD IS THAT SOME OF THE
UNDERLYING ASSESSMENT- YOU KNOW
WERE IMPACTED AS A RESULT OF
THE PANDEMIC CAN CONTINUE TO BE
IMPACTED. SO THAT THERE'S YOU
KNOW IT'S CERTAINLY A TEMPORARY
PAUSE THERE THAT SAID- THERE OR
THE LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS. THAT AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL ARE SUPPOSED TO
SPEAK TO- YOU KNOW THE
DIFFERENT OFFERINGS AND THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS IN THE
DIFFERENT SERVICES BEING
PROVIDED TO STUDENTS. BUT BUT
THE CHALLENGE WAS IS THAT WHAT
THE ALL CAPS THE WHOLE POINT OF
THE DASHBOARD IS BECAUSE- SAY
MIKE MORRELL CAPTAIN THINK IT'S
TWO HUNDRED PAGES FROM MY
DISTRICT SO- EVEN I CAN'T. EVEN
I HAVE A HARD TIME DISCERNING
THAT THE WHOLE POINT AS- MR
GALLAGHER POINT OUT WAS HAVING
THIS DASHBOARD WAS TO PROVIDE.
ACCOUNTABILITY TO NOT ONLY WE
COULD LOOK AT THAT THE PUBLIC
COULD LOOK AT SO. WHY WHY HAS A
DASHBOARD NOT BEEN PUT UP WITH
THE INFORMATION THAT WE DO HAVE
WE UNDERSTAND THAT. SOMETIMES
WHEN I GIVEN LAST YEAR THEY
WERE NOT GIVEN THE YEAR BEFORE-
BUT OUTSIDE OF THAT WHY WASN'T
HE AT LEAST PARTIALLY FILLED
OUT. YEAH I THINK GIVEN GIVEN
THE TYPE OF INFORMATION THAT
WAS GOING TO BEING PULLED. UP
TO BE REPORTED IN THE
DASHBOARD- YOU KNOW GIVEN AND
THEN. YOU KNOW WORKING OUT WITH
A- AND ASSESSMENTS THAT HAVE
NOT OCCURRED I'M BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC OR DELAYED BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC- WE FELT IT
PRUDENT TO DELAY THE DASHBOARD.
SO WHEN YOU PUT UP THE NEXT
ASKED WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO
HAVE A GAP OF TWO YEARS. WELL
CERTAINLY I'LL I'LL HAPPILY
CONNECT WITH. YOU KNOW MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION TO- YOU KNOW GET
BACK TO YOU ON THAT PARTICULAR
ASPECT GREAT IF THEY CAN
RESPOND IN WRITING TO THE
COMMITTEE WOULD APPRECIATE IT.
JORDAN THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
THAT- I JUST WANTED TO POINT
OUT I'M NOT SURE WHY THIS WAS
THE CASE- AND PERHAPS TO GET AN
ANSWER IS- THE REMOVAL. AT THE
SCHOOLS FOR THE DEAF AND THE
AND THE BLIND IN THE PROGRAM
FOR FIVE FOR THE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS- WOULD THINK THAT. THE
STUDENTS SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE BUT
SOMEHOW THEY'VE BEEN REMOVED IN
THIS TRAILER BILL- FROM BEING
ABLE TO BE QUALIFIED TO BE
ELIGIBLE FOR THAT SAVINGS
PROGRAM. I DON'T THINK WE CAN
HELP PROGRAM THAT THAT I WAS
PROPOSED- INCLUDES TWO
COMPONENTS THERE. SHOULD COME.
A THAT IS FUNDED IT BURKE AND
AVAILABLE. INS AND THEN THERE
ARE SUPPLEMENTAL DEPOSITS THAT
ARE FOCUSED ON OUR LOW INCOME
STUDENTS ARE ALL STREET YOUTH
ARE HOMELESS STUDENTS- THAT
WOULD BE MADE- YOU KNOW WHEN A
STUDENT ENTERS FIRST GRADE AND
IN THE FIRST YEAR IT WOULD BE
FOR ALL STUDENTS IN GRADES ONE
THROUGH TWELVE AFTER THAT
SUPPLEMENTAL DEPOSIT AND HE'S
HAD WHICH MEANT OF THE CALKINS
ACCOUNT FOR THOSE ST. YEAH MY
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'VE
ACTUALLY REMOVE LIKE STUDENTS
WHO ARE AT THE STATE SCHOOLS
FOR THE DEAF AND THE BLIND.
THOSE STUDENTS DON'T QUALIFY. I
KNOW THAT THAT'S NOT MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE. AND IT IF THAT
IS THE CASE YOU KNOW WILL
CERTAINLY WORK WITH STAFF TO
LOOK INTO THAT IT. OKAY SO
MOVING I RESPOND BACK TO ME I
BELIEVE THAT WAS THE CASE I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S NOT THE CASE. MR
GALLAGHER BURKE MAYBE I COULD
RECOMMEND TOP PERHAPS OR STAFF
COULD. EMAIL FINANCE WITH THE
IT BUT THE AREA. THAT THEY
FOUND IN THE PREVIOUS BILL
THAT. FOR SOME REASON THEY CAN
FIND IN THIS NEW. THE NET AND
HOPEFULLY ON THE SAME PAGE OKAY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MISTER
BENNETT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF.
SURE. I'M GOING TO BE VERY
NEARLY FOCUS MY COMMENTS ARE
JUST ONE PART OF THE BUDGET-
DIRECTLY RELATE. TO AND MY ANA.
OKAY I'M A VERY NEARLY DIRECTOR
OF MY COMMENTS OF ONE PART OF
THE BUDGET- ONE WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY ALL OF US ON THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE ALL OF US IN
THE LEGISLATURE. TO MAKE SURE
THAT- WE TRY TO CREATE AS MUCH
ACCOUNTABILITY AS WE POSSIBLY
CAN EACH YEAR WHEN WE ADOPTED
BUDGET AND THAT MEANS REVIEWING
HOW THE MONEY WAS SPENT LAST
YEAR. HOW EFFECTIVELY WAS THAT
MONEY SPENT AND WHAT SHOULD WE
DO DIFFERENTLY A WITH
ALLOCATIONS IN TERMS OF GOING
FORWARD AND WHEN YOU HAVE
ONGOING COMMITMENT TO FUNDING
IT JUST MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT
AND MORE CHALLENGING- TO DO
THAT KIND OF OVERSIGHT I'M NOT
SAYING THAT WE SHOULD HAVE SOME
ONGOING COMMITMENT. BUT WHEN
YOU HAVE IT I THINK HE
RECOGNIZES STAKEHOLDERS EXCITER
HAVE EXPECTATIONS AND THEY HAVE
FEWER EXPECTATIONS IN TERMS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. UP IN TERMS OF
FIRE PREVENTION SPENDING- I
CERTAINLY COME FROM AS MANY OF
US TO VERY HIGH FIRE. RISK
AREA- WE'VE HAD SOME
TREMENDOUS- FIRES IN IN THE
AREA- AND I AM VERY INTERESTED
IN FIRE PREVENTION- SPENDING IT
IN IN THE BUDGET- BUT I WOULD
OFFER I RAISE THIS ISSUE OF MY
VERY FIRST BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE
HEARING AND THAT IS THAT. THE
SCIENCE OF THE POLICY ON FIRE
PREVENTION IS CERTAINLY TO ME
PRETTY SQUISHY. IT'S PRETTY
HARD TO SAY WHAT IS THE BEST
EXPENDITURE OF FIRE PREVENTION
MONEY. AND I THINK IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN A MAJOR
FOCUS- IN THE PAST AND SO I
THINK IT'S VERY APPROPRIATE FOR
US TO MOVE CAUTIOUSLY. IT'S OUR
BIGGER RISK BUT WE HAVE THIS
MUCH MONEY TO SPEND IS THAT A
YEAR FROM NOW WE HAVE ALL KINDS
OF STORIES ABOUT HOW MONEY WAS
WASTED NOT SPENT WELL LOOK
CENTER AND SO THE IDEA THAT
THIS IN OUR CURRENT BUDGET
WHICH IS TO TRY TO. MOVE
METHODICALLY AND MAKE SURE WE
GET MAXIMUM BANG FOR THE BUCK
IS ONE THAT I THINK MAKES SENSE
EVEN THOUGH I AM FROM AN AREA
THAT DEBT WOULD BE EASY TO SAY
YOU KNOW THE MORE MONEY FOR
FIRE PREVENTION TO SORT OF
BETTER IT IS POLITICALLY- BUT I
THINK WE HAVE A LONGER RANGE
RESPONSIBILITY. AND THAT IS TO
MAKE SURE WE DO IT RESPONSIBLY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
APPROVED YOUR COMMENTS MISTER
BENNETT I KNOW THE MISTER BLOOM
AS WE TALKED ABOUT EARLIER IS
GOING TO BE. DOING A SEPARATE
HEARING TO. TO DELVE INTO THAT
EXACT ISSUE AND ARE YOU ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE SO. APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK THERE. OTHER OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. BECAUSE I'M NOT
SEEING ANY WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT- ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE ROOM TO COME UP
TO THE MIKE. YOU'RE FREE TO
COME FOR GONNA GIVE EVERYBODY
IN THE ROOM A MINUTE AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINE.
FIGURE SKATING THE OTHER HALF
OF THE BUILDING FOR EXAMPLE
HERE THE LATEST ON OPPOSITION.
THAT THAT IT'S ALL GOOD YEAH.
THERE WE GO. IS THAT BETTER
OKAY THANK YOU AGAIN JEREMY
SMITH HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL- HERE AND- TODAY
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO SECTION
SIXTY SEVEN OF SB ONE THIRTY TO
THE HIGHER EDUCATION TRAILER
BILL THAT IS BEFORE YOU TODAY.
SUCH AS IF YOU SEVEN OF THIS
BILL WOULD LEVERAGE THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CONSTRUCTION BUDGET. TO ADVANCE
THE PRIORITIES OF ASK ME LOCAL
THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE BY
PLACING ALL THE CONSTRUCTION
CAPITAL OUTLAY FUNDS FOR THE
UC. INTO AN ESCROW ACCOUNT WITH
THE STATE COMPTROLLER. AND TELL
YOU SEE IN A THIRD PARTY CAN
CERTIFY- THE INFORMATION THEY
NEED FROM THE UC. THE TERM
PUBLIC FUNDS. IS SO BROADLY
DEFINED THAT MEANS ANY KIND OF
STATE FUNDS ANY DEBT FINANCING
AND GRANTS PROVIDED THE
UNIVERSITY THIS SCHEME WILL
SIGNIFICANTLY CURTAIL UC'S
ABILITY TO FINANCE EVERY
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT INCLUDING
THOSE THAT WOULD ADDRESS LIFE
SAFETY NEEDS. MEDICAL HOSPITAL
FACILITIES AND STUDENT HOUSING
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THIS FREEZE ON CONSTRUCTION
WOULD PROHIBIT EVEN CRITICALLY
NEEDED SEISMIC UPGRADES ARE YOU
SEE HOSPITALS. UNIVERSITY
APPEARS TO BE PROHIBITED FROM
SPENDING ARE YOU IN PLEDGING
CONSTRUCTION FUNDS UNTIL THREE
SEPARATE CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICES
THE DEPARTMENT ANNOUNCED THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND THE STATE
COMPTROLLER PROVIDE PRIOR
APPROVAL WHICH IS NOT DEFINED.
NOW IS NOT THE TIME TO PUT IN
LIMBO ONE GROUP OF WORKERS
LIVELIHOODS EARNING POTENTIAL
BENEFITS AND THE PUBLIC'S
SAFETY IN ORDER TO ADVANCE THE
INTERESTS OF ANOTHER SET OF
WORKERS. IT IS FOR THESE
REASONS THAT WE OPPOSE
SPECIFICALLY SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN OF SB ONE THREE TWO AND
URGE YOU TO REMOVE IT BEFORE
FINAL PASSAGE THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN IN
DRAMATIC HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
NORTHEASTERN CALIFORNIA
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ONE WEEK
KNOWLEDGE MY PERSONAL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MR GALLAGHER. THANK HIM
FOR HIS QUESTIONS ON THIS
TOPIC. ON BEHALF OF OUR MEMBERS
THAT LIVE IN THE NORTHEASTERN
PART OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE ASKING
THAT YOU REJECT THE PROVISIONS
OF SECTION SIXTY SEVEN WE DON'T
BELIEVE THE MEN AND WOMEN
OF THE BUILDING TRADE SHOULD BE
HELD HOSTAGE. IN TERMS OF-
THEIR WORK AND THEIR LIVELIHOOD
TO ADVANCE THE CAUSES OF SAW
SOMEONE ELSE OR ANOTHER GROUP.
WITH THAT- AGAIN I ASK FOR YOUR
OPPOSITION TO SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIKE WEST
ON BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES I WANT TO ECHO THE-
SENTIMENTS MY COLLEAGUES FROM
THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN. THE PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES LIVELIHOOD SHOULDN'T BE
HELD HOSTAGE- BASED ON ANOTHER
ORGANIZATIONS GOALS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MATT CRIMMINS HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ABOUT A
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS I WOULD ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MR SMITH WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES- WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION TO SEX A SECTION
SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. IN
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE
MONACAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS. THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL. THE WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL SHEET METAL WORKERS. IN
THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS. STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SECTION SIXTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THEN KURT WITH THE CARPENTERS
UNION OR MAKE TWO QUICK POINTS-
IF YOU DON'T BUILD BUILDINGS
YOU CAN'T MAINTAIN THEM SO
THAT'S A PROBLEM HERE. AND THAT
SEEMS TO BE THE ISSUE AT THE-
THEY WERE DISCUSSING AND THE
OTHER IS IF THERE'S ALREADY AN
AGREEMENT ABOUT OUT SOARED
SOURCING MAINTENANCE. AND IT'S
NOT BEING FOLLOWED BY THE
UNIVERSITY THE ANSWER IS NOT TO
MAKE THE OUTSOURCING AGREEMENT
MORE COMPLICATED AND DIFFICULT
CAN ACTUALLY THREATEN BUILDING.
IS TO FIND A WAY TO MAKE SURE
THE UNIVERSITY MEETS THE
ALREADY STATUTORY REQUIREMENT
NOT MAKE IT MORE COMPLICATED
BECAUSE IF THEY'RE NOT MEETING
IT WHY WOULD THEY MEET THE MORE
COMPLICATED ONE. SO GRAPPLE
WITH THATFOR A LITTLE BIT BUT
WE OPPOSE THAT PARTICULAR
SECTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER COMMENTS IN THE ROOM
WHERE THE GALLERY. OKAY SEEING
NON WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINE OPERATOR FOR YOUR.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AT THE
END OF THE ROW AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT SIXTY
COMMENCING Q. WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO SIXTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
FEARING FOR THE SAN DIEGO
HUMANE. EFE-EPA THINKING YOU
KNOW CORD CUTTING THE ANIMAL
SHELTER AT THE CAN ACT IN SB
ONE THIRTY TO AT SECTION SIXTY
EIGHT MANY UNDER REPORTS
COMMUNITY SHELTER FAMILIES AND
ANIMALS WILL BE SERVED BY THIS
NEW PROGRAM THANK YOU. SECTION.
SIXTY SEVEN HUNDRED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN TO FIFTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS BONNIE NINETY I'M A MINORITY
AND A PAIR OF INDEPENDENT STUDY
STUDENTS I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE
PROPOSED CHANGES TO INDEPENDENT
STUDY PROGRAM INCLUDING AB ONE
THIRTEEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN TO FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON XIN
GASPING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL. OPPOSED TO
SECTION SIXTY SEVEN OF SB ONE
THIRTY TWO- NOT ONLY DOES THIS
NEGATIVELY IMPACT OUR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS IN THE BUILDING
TRADES BUT IT ALSO NEGATIVELY
IMPACTS OUR FOURTEEN THOUSAND
MEMBERS AT B. C. WHO. RELY ON
THESE PROJECTS TO HAVE SAFE
ENVIRONMENTS IN THE WORKPLACE-
WE URGE YOUR OPPOSITION OF THIS
PARTICULAR PROVISION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN TO- THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE TWO ZERO THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD- LOPER TRYING YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD NOPE. IN EVERYONE MY
NAME'S GOING TO BE TREATED WITH
THE NOW TRACY THIRTY SIX ON
BEHALF OF THE AFTER PART HERE
IN SOUTHERN WEEKS OF THIS BILL
DEFINITELY THANK YOU BUT. THANK
YOU RYAN TWO SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ALEX CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE LEARNING CARE GROUP
NORTH AMERICA'S SECOND LARGEST
FOR PROFIT CHILD CARE PROVIDER.
WE ARE CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO THE
WAY UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN STRUCTURED AND
THEREFORE MUST OPPOSE THOSE
PROVISIONS OF AB ONE THIRTY. WE
URGE MEMBERS TO CONSIDER THE
BENEFITS THE NEXT DELIVERY
SYSTEM. WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT
A ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH IS
APPROPRIATE FOR THE NEEDS OF
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN OUR
DIVERSE STATE. AND WE WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT THIS PROPOSAL
COMES AT A TIME WHEN A CHILD
CARE SYSTEM IS AT ITS MOST
FRAGILE WITH NEARLY EIGHTY FIVE
HUNDRED RECENT CLOSURES.
EXPANDING TO CATER ALL FAMILIES
WITHOUT THINKING THROUGH THE
EFFECTS ON CHILD CARE IS A
WORST CASE SCENARIO FOR THE
FIELD. AND WILL PUSH ABOUT THAT
SPRING. LOCKLEY MEMBERS SHOULD
NOT ASSUME ALL CHILD CARE FOR.
CAN ON ZERO TO THREE OLDS. TO
MAKE UP FOR THE LOSS EMPLOYER
OLD. THIS IS. BECAUSE MANY
PROGRAMS WOULD NEED TO GET
RELICENSED AND RECEIVE SPECIFIC
TRAINING TO ACCEPT YOUNGER
CHILDREN. DIFFERENT STAFFING
STAFFING RATIOS AND OTHER COSTS
WOULD ALSO ENSURE THAT PRICES
PER FAMILIES WOULD TRY. WOULD
RISE DRASTICALLY. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO ENGAGE
AS THESE PROPOSALS IMPORTANT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TO
EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MISTER CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS PROGRAM OF
KARACHI ELLIOT CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION CONSORTIUM WE ARE
NONPROFIT ALLIANCE OF LIFE HIGH
QUALITY CHILD CARE PRESCHOOL
PROVIDERS- THAT OPERATE- COOK
OVER FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY CENTERS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA EMPLOYEE
COSTS NINE THOUSAND EDUCATORS
AND STAFF AND THIRD OF OVER
FORTY THOUSAND CHILDREN IN ARE
YOU SEE E. CENTERS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE REPRESENTED
MAKES A SUBSIDY PRIVATE PAY AN
ON SITE CARE AND SERVICES THAT
SUPPORT FAMILIES AND CHILDREN
FROM DIVERSE CULTURAL AND
SOCIAL ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS WE
UNFORTUNATELY MUCH OPPOSED SB
ONE THIRTY DUE TO THE
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROPOSAL THAT IS INCLUDED IN
THAT- THAT WILL LIMIT THE
ABILITY FOR PARENTS TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE THEIR CHILDREN ADD- ANY
OF THE COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS
AND FORCE THEM INTO THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM AS THE ONLY FREE
OPTION UNDER THIS BILL. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS AND OTHER REASONS
OUTLINED BY THE LEARNING CARE
GROUP THAT SPEAKER BEFORE ME WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. SB
ONE THIRTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN TO EIGHTY THREE PER SCORE.
YES MY NAME IS WRITER OP WITH
THIS PURPOSE IN OUT LIKE CRAZY
BUT WE DON'T STATE BUILDING
BLOC THIS ASPECT SIX SEVEN
THANK. THANK YOU LINE TO EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON HAPPY WITH PUBLIC I
WHEN I THINK YES I AND HUMAN
YOUR TREMENDOUS RECOGNIZE
EDUCATION BUDGET SB ONE THIRTY
WE'RE THRILLED TO SEE OUR CALLS
FOR A BEST INVESTMENT YOU
RACIALLY TRUST RELATIONSHIP
CENTER COMMUNITY SCHOOL
REFLECTED IN THE THREE BILLION
PROVIDED FOR THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOL PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM. HE
PLUS THE MORE THAN TWO BILLION
ALLOCATED FOR CRITICAL EDUCATOR
RECRUITMENT TRAINING AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
TRACK AND SUPPORT DIVERSE
MARKER PAY TEACHERS WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE CHANGES TO THE SEA
BASS TO PERMIT QUALIFYING
COURSE WORK TO DEMONSTRATE
SUBJECT MATTER PROFICIENCY. WE
SUPPORT THE INCREASE TO THE
OSTEOPATH CONCENTRATION GRANT
AND COMMAND THE STATE REQUIRED
BY THE LAW AND IMPROVING YOUR
CAP TEMPLATE TO ENSURE THAT
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS GENERATED
ANNUALLY BY LOW INCOME STUDENTS
ENGLISH LEARNERS EVEN FOSTER
CARE ARE USED AS INTENDED TO
INCREASE IMPROVE SERVICES FOR
THOSE HIGH NEED STUDENTS. WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE GREATER
TRANSPARENCY WILL BE REQUIRED
FROM ALLEY AS AND THE L.
CAPPING OFF THE OTHER PLANS AND
USE OF SUPPLEMENTAL AND FEDERAL
STIMULUS FUNDS MEDINA THIRTEEN
BILLION IN OUR BUDGET THREE
FUNDS AND BILLIONS IN
CATEGORICAL. LASTLY WE SUPPORT
THE MORE THAN SIX MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT TO HELP
SCHOOL DISTRICT THE SCHOOL
CLIMATE SURVEY TO IMPROVE
SCHOOL COMMUNITY. LIKE FORTY
USING THIS UNPRECEDENTED
OPPORTUNITY TO REIMAGINE OUR
SCHOOLS AND ADDRESS THE ROOT
CAUSES OF EDUCATION EQUITY IN
CALIFORNIA I THOUGHT DURING THE
PLACES. YOU TO CONTEMPT THANK
YOU AGAIN. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON- THIS CHAIRMAN
OF THE BELIEVE IT THIS CALLING
ON THE OF THE ASSOCIATE GENERAL.
TO CALIFORNIA ONE ALIGN OUR
CONCERNS WITH THOSE OF THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES- WITH
SECTION SIXTY SEVEN ON SB ONE
THIRTY TWO THAT- PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT THE TERRIBLE
PRECEDENT- ON ISSUES THAT DEAL
WITH CONSTRUCTION AND WE URGE
THAT IT BE TAKEN OUT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN TO NINETY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CAPTAIN AGREEMENT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES WE
SUPPORT THE FUNDING FOR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION AND WE
SUGGEST WORKING CLOSELY WITH
LOCAL GVERNMENTS IS WHERE THE
FRONT LINES OF THIS WILD CARDS
BECOME MORE AND MORE DANGEROUS
IN COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE FUNDING DOES NOT NEED TO
GO THROUGH CAL FIRE BUT CAN BE
ALLOCATED TO REGIONAL ENTITIES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE OTHER
FIRE PREVENTION PARTNERS. BUT
WE CAN APPLY FOR FUNDING OR
SPEND FUNDING WITHOUT SOME SORT
OF PROGRAM OUR PLANT COUNTIES
ARE PREPARED TO SIT DOWN AND
JOIN ANY CONVERSATION THAT WILL
ENSURE THAT THE FUNDING IS USED
TO SUPPORT OUR COMMUNITY WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION AND QUICK ACTION
ON THE ALLOCATION OF WATER
FUNDING THANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD
WORK ON THIS DIFFICULT SUBJECT.
THANK YOU RYAN TO SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GRAB. YEAH GIOVANNA LOCK
HUMBOLDT DEL NORD BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES WE STAND IN
OPPOSITION TO SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN TO SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ALLEY
MCDANIEL ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN
THAN A COMPREHENSIVE CHILDREN'S
AGENCY IN LOS ANGELES WORKING
TO TRANSFORM THE LIVES OF
CHILDREN EXPOSED TO TRAUMA AND
ADVERSITY WE WANT TO THANK THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT FOR
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS NONPROFITS
LIKE CHILDREN'S AND IF YOU ARE
KEY TO THE THINK THAT THE
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS WHICH IS
CREATED IN PARTNERSHIP BUT
LEVERAGED ESTABLISHED AND
TRUSTED NETWORK OF COMMUNITY
BASED RESOURCES. OPERATIVE TO
GENERATION APPROACHES THE
PORTHOLE THE CHILD AND FAMILY
WELL BEING IS EXACT. ANCHORED
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION HEAD
START CENTERS CHILDREN BUT DID
YOU ESTABLISH A COMMUNITY
SCHOOL NEARBY ELEMENTARY MIDDLE
AND HIGH SCHOOLS. FORMING A
PATHWAY SO THAT EXACTLY CAN BE
BUILT PARTS AN INTEGRATED THE
COURTNEY PROVIDED OVERTIME FOR
QUALITY LEARNING HEALTHY
DEVELOPMENT AND LONG TERM WHILE
THAT. WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
EXPANSION OF QUALITY COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. CHANGE
YOUR MIND TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS JAMES
CHARACTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL WAIVERS- WOULD
LIKE TO LINE OUR COMMENTS WITH
THOSE OF JEREMY SMITH WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO SECTION SIXTY SEVEN
OF SB ONE THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN TO EIGHTY NINE
THREE SCORE HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAMBER AND BRING TRIED WITH
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE LA WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR THE INCLUSION OF
THE FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AND SB
ONE L. ONE THREE WHAT THIRTY
FORTY EIGHT- YOU COMPLETION
EQUIPMENT CORRECT. I THANK YOU
SO MUCH AT. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MANY NARAL
CO MODERATE BANKERS COUNTY
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL STRONG OPPOSITION TO
SECTION SIXTY SEVEN SP ONE
THIRTY TWO WHAT THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN TO NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND HOW THAT WOULD END WITH
WIDENING GROUP SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF NEXT IN CALIFORNIA WE
WANT TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE FACT THAT CALIFORNIA
DREAM ACT APPLICATION
COMPLETION REQUIREMENT AND AT
THE ONE THIRTY TWO AND THEN
BACK MEN OF FIVE HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME PROP
NINETEEN FUNDS. FOR THE EIGHT
RUDY COMPLETION IMPROVEMENT
GRANT PROGRAM IN SB ONE THIRTY
WANT TO THANK YOU THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
FOR THE INCLUSION OF THE
FOOTBALL CLUB IN THE BUDGET
THAT WILL SUPPORT STUDENTS IN
OBTAINING A HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND MORE PROSPEROUS FUTURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TO
TWENTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. TOM
WYMAN SAN DIEGO BUILDING TRADES
CALLING IN OPPOSITION ALIGNING
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
THE- INSIGHTFUL COMMENTS FROM
JEREMY SPENCER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT ONE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE CALL AT. HI MY
NAME IS AMBER GONZALEZ WITH A
SMART SHEET METAL WORKERS LOCAL
ONE ZERO FIVE THE NEW THE
BUILDING TRADES OPPOSITION
SECOND SIXTY SEVEN SB ONE
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU MUCH.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I'M RON MILLER
EXECUTIVE SECRETARY OF THE LA
ORANGE COUNTY BUILDING TRADES
SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF A
HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND SKILLED
AND TRAINED MEN AND WOMEN. IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP ONE THIRTY
TWO SECTION SIXTY SEVEN WE
STAND IN OPPOSITION WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN TO FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO OUT. CATHERINE MY
BURGER PRESIDENT OF APPS NEED
THIRTY TWO NINETY NINE
REPRESENTING UC'S SERVICE
WORKERS IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
THIRTY. FOR THE PAST SIX YEARS
WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON THREE BILLS
THREE BUDGET LANGUAGE
PROVISIONS AND A CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT. WE'VE GONE THROUGH
ALL SEE AND FISCAL COMMITTEES
DOZENS OF TIMES AND EARNED
HUNDREDS OF YES VOTES. AND YET
UC'S STILL INSISTS ON
OUTSOURCING JANITORS WHO CLEAN
THE TOILETS GROUNDSKEEPERS WHO
MOW THEIR GRASS AND COOKS WHO
PREPARE THEIR FOOD. THIS YEAR
SB ONE THIRTY TWO PROPOSES TO
CLOSE LOOPHOLES THAT UC FOUND
IN LAST YEAR'S LANGUAGE TO
CONTINUE OUTSOURCING. AND LIKE
LAST YEAR SB ONE THIRTY TWO
DOES NOT UC'S CONSTITUTIONAL
AUTONOMY. AND LIKE THE
PREVAILING WAGE LAW THIS
LANGUAGE CONDITIONS PUBLIC
FUNDING TO A STANDARD THAT
REFLECT THEIR VALUES AND OURS.
THE CUSTODIANS COOKS
GROUNDSKEEPERS AND MAINTENANCE
WORKERS FOR WHOM I SPEAK WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS GREG HARTMAN I'M
REPRESENTING THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS
LOCAL LAKE AND I'M CALLING TO
STRONGLY OPPOSE SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN OF. SENATE BILL ONE
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN ONE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
GLAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ROB STOKER
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF SHEET
METAL WORKERS LOCAL ONE OH FOUR
AND THE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY. AND WE STAND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN THEIR
OPPOSITION TO SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN WOULD ASK THAT YOU WOULD
REJECT THAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT AWAY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ANTHONY DISK
YOU SELL REPRESENTATIVE PETER
FROST INSULATORS LOCAL SIXTEEN
AND WE'RE ALSO STANDING WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION TO SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN AND STATE SENATE BILL ONE
THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY ONE FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS MARKED OUT FROM
INTERNTIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS FIVE NINE
FIVE REPRESENTING ALAMEDA
COUNTY WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES OPPOSITIONS TO
SB THIRTY TWO SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT INTO TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS MIXED WITH
WATER I AM AT THE IBEW LOCAL
SIX EIGHTY FOUR WHICH
REPRESENTS OVER FIVE HUNDRED
WORKERS AND THEIR FAMILIES AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND WE'RE
JOINING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION OF SB ONE
THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU. GOING TO
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS COREY
VAN RIDES THE VALLEY BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. ONE THIRTY TWO SECTION
SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RYAN ONE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE EMBERS
MY NAME IS ISAAC PELAS ON
BEHALF OF THE LABORERS
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF NORTH
AMERICA PACIFIC SOUTHWEST
REGIONAL OFFICE AND TWENTY TWO
AFFILIATED CALIFORNIA LOCAL
UNIONS WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
TO SECTION SIXTY SEVEN OF
SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY TWO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE FOR YOM ON
BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
BROTHERHOOD OF BOILERMAKERS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SECTION
SIXTY SEVEN OF SB ONE THIRTY
TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN HOLD IBEW
LOCAL FOUR TO EIGHT KERN COUNTY
WE ARE ALSO STANDING WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION AFFECTION SIXTY
SEVEN OF THAT THE ONE THIRTY
TWO. THANK YOU RYAN ONE EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO OUT. GOOD
AFTERNOON COUNCIL MY NAME IS
EDDIE PENNY ON THE BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE HEATER
PRODUCT INSULATORS FAR STOPPERS
OF LOCAL PARK SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE STANDING STRONG
SUPPORT. WHAT THE REST OF THE
BUILDING TRADES. OPPOSING ONE
THIRTY TWO SECTION SIXTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE JEDI ALVAREZ
WITH THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
BUILDING STRUCTURE EIGHT
COUNCIL- WE STAND WITH OUR
BROTHERS AND SISTERS ACROSS
STATE AND THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES OPPOSING SB. ONE THREE
TWO SIX SIX SEVEN. THANKS VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU RYAN ONE SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN WHENEVER
COMMITTEE JEFFRIES ON THE BOB
WILL MAKE IT LOOK A LOT FIVE
FOUR NINE BUSINESS MANAGER I'VE
BEEN IN OPPOSITION ASCEND AND
IN UNISON WITH STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION OF OUR
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY TWO
SECTION SIXTY SEVEN
SPECIFICALLY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO OUT. HELLO
I'M MARK PRATT WHITNEY BAKER
LOCAL COURT THIRTY WIND BROTHEL
CALIFORNIA AND WE GOING TO
BILLION TRADE NOT THEIR
OPPOSITION ON SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN OF AB ONE THIRTY TWO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
SEVENTY PLEASE GLAD. HI THERE-
TO MR CHECK- MISTER CHAIR AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CHRISTOPHER BURNETT OF
GLAZERS- YOUR PURCHASE GO LOCAL
SEVEN ONE EIGHT DISTRICT
COUNCILS SIXTEEN. OF I U. P. A.
T. THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES
DURING THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION TO SECTION
SIXTY SEVEN OF US SB ONE THIRTY
TWO ONE AB ONE THIRTY TWO I
BELIEVE ASK ME IS CREATING A
DANGEROUS PRECEDENT TO LEVERAGE
CONSTRUCTION JOBS. AND HOUSING
AND THE EXPANSION OF OUR
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS FOR
POLITICAL PAY BACK AND I
BELIEVE IT NEEDS TO BE REMOVED
I URGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANG AND
SENATOR SKINNER NOT TO ACCEPT
ANY- LEGISLATION IN PARLIAMENT
THE CONTAINS THAT LANGUAGE AND
ON A PERSONAL NOTE MY MOTHER
DOES WORK FOR THE K. POP
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FOR THE DEAF.
IN FREMONT AND A COMMITTEE
MEMBER ALSO MENTIONED CONCERN
ABOUT REMOVING LANGUAGE TO-
SUPPORT- THOSE STUDENTS AT THAT
FACILITY SO I. WOULD ECHO THOSE
CONCERNS AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN TO- FOR CALL.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS PETER
SENT WITH THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT COUNCIL
LABOR'S. AND WE'RE JOINING THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN THE
OPPOSITION OF SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN OF SP ONE THIRTY TWO AB
ONE THIRTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT ONE EIGHTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO ARE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT THE INITIAL
BUT STILL ON THE UP THE IRON
WORKERS LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN WE
FOUND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN STRONG OPPOSITION
PROTECTION FIFTY SEVEN ABOUT
THE ONE THIRTY TWO. ALL OF.
THANK YOU NINETEEN NINETY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE HAVE THE
CEMENT MASONS SO THE CALIFORNIA
ALONG SIDE OF THE BUILDING
TRADES. LOWS SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN OF EIGHTY ONE THIRTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TO
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON THE TO SAY
YOU'RE PRETENDING FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA USED
TO STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SP ONE
THIRTY TWO SECTION SIXTY SEVEN
WE REQUEST THE COMMITTEE TO
DELAY APPROVAL OF S. B. ONE
THIRTY TWO UNTIL TEXANS FIFTY
SEVEN IS REMOVED FROM THE BILL.
YOU SEE IF THERE IS A CONCERN
WITH THE BUILDS PROHIBITION ON
SPENDING OR EVEN PLEDGING ANY
CONSTRUCTION FUNDS PENDING A
THIRD PARTY AUDIT EACH YEAR
THIS WOULD INTERRUPT CURRENT
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS WHILE
JEOPARDIZING FUTURE PROJECTS
INCLUDING THOSE ADDRESSING
SIXTY THIRTY HOUSING AND
HOSPITAL FACILITIES. YOUR SEATS
CURRENTLY HAS SEVEN POINT EIGHT
BILLION IN CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS PROVIDING THOUSANDS OF
LOCAL JOBS THAT COULD BE
JEOPARDIZED. YOU SEE IS ALSO
CONCERNED WITH THE SPECIAL
DEPOSIT ACCOUNT FOR ALL YOU SEE
CAPITAL OUTLAY FUNDING
CONTROLLED BY THE STATE
CONTROLLER AS WELL AS TO
REQUIREMENTS FOR DIRECT
EMPLOYMENT WITH NO EXCEPTIONS
LIKE EMERGENCY WOULD HAVE
ALREADY BEEN AGREED TO BY THE
REPRESENTED SERVICE WORKERS
THANK YOU SEE. YOU SEE
CURRENTLY HAVE A CONTRACT WITH
TOPS ME PROHIBITED MOST
CONTRACTING OUT AS WELL AS THE
REGION'S POLICY GENERALLY
PROHIBITING CONTRACTING OUT
PLEASE REJECT. SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT AWAY SIX SIX PLEASE CALL
AHEAD. AND ONE SIX SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE TWO EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS BART ON BAR I'M A DISTRICT
UP TO SIXTY PAGES WHILE I
TRADE. WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADE IN OPPOSITION
ABOUT WE WANT THEM TO. SECTION
FIFTY SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RYAN ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KEVIN FERRER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE SACRAMENTO SEARS
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL AND WE STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES AND OPPOSING
SECTION SIXTY SEVEN OF SB ONE
THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU YOUR MIND TWO SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
DANNY RIGHT WITH THE UNITED
SOLICITATION OF PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS. WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF SEX SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN OF SP ONE THIRTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TO TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THIS IS A VETS BUT
ALSO WITH THE BRICKLAYERS AND
TILE LAYERS LOCAL BREED
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WE
STAND IS NOT STRONG OPPOSITION.
OF SECTION SIXTY SEVEN ON SB
ONE THIRTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ARE TRYING TO EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS ROMAN FARE FROM THE
LABORS PACIFIC SOUTHWEST REGION
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE SECTION
SIXTY SEVEN OF SP ONE THIRTY
TWO ALONG WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS A
TURKEY HELLO YEAH I DETER THE
LOCAL FIVE NINE FIVE
REPRESENTING ELIGIBLE WORKERS
IN ALAMEDA AND SAN JOAQUIN IN
CALAVERAS COUNTY AND WE STAND
ALONGSIDE THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES COUNCIL HANDED IN STRONG
OPPOSITION I HAVE SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN. SENATE BILL WONDERS YEAH
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS BENITO
ROLLED ARMY FIELD
REPRESENTATIVE YOU HAVE TO
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF LABORERS FROM CALI
TO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SIXTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN OF FIFTY ONE THIRTY
TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
TO CHANNEL PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JOHN HENRY LOPEZ IN WHAT THE
UNITED ASSOCIATION OF PLUMBERS
AND PIPEFITTERS REPRESENTING
FRESNO MADERA TULARE AND KINGS
COUNTIES AND WE STAND IN STRONG
OPPOSITION WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES OF SECTION
SIXTY SEVEN. OF S. B. ONE
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN TO THIRTY SEVEN TREES GO
OUT. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
GLENN LOVE ALL OF THE IRON
WORKERS UNION LOCAL THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT RPM WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO PROVISIONS IN A
QUARTER SECTION SIXTY SEVEN OF
S. B. ONE THIRTY TWO ONCE AGAIN
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS MIKE
WITH THE IBEW LOCAL SIX EIGHTY
FOUR AND I'M JOINING THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES AND OPPOSITION
OF THE SPECIFIED BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TO FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS ON MY CANTERBURY
BUSINESS AGENT WITH TEAMSTERS
LOCAL EIGHT FIFTY THREE IN
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA WE STAND
STRONG OPPOSITION TO S. B. ONE
THIRTY CHIU SECTION SIXTY SEVEN
BECAUSE OF THE NEGATIVE IMPACT-
LAB ARE MEMBERS AND MEMBERS OF
THE BUILDING TRADES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU RYAN CHIU
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON ELIZABETH OR CALLING
ON BEHALF OF BEST FRIENDS
ANIMAL SOCIETY AND OUR
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA MEMBERS
SUPPORTERS PARTNERS AND STAFF
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND GRATITUDE
FOR THE INCLUSION OF FUNDING
FOR THE ANIMAL SHELTER
ASSISTANCE ACT IN SECTION SIXTY
EIGHT OF SB ONE THIRTY TWO THIS
IS A MUCH NEEDED OPPORTUNITY
FOR OUR STATE TO PROVIDE
CRITICAL SUPPORT IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. SUPPORT FAMILIES
AND TAXPAYERS AN HONOR THE
STATE'S COMMITMENT NOT TO KILL
ANY HEALTHY OR TREATABLE
ANIMALS FOR SPACE THAT WE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU RYAN TO THIRTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU.
THIRTY TWO. JUNE NINETEENTH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS DAN TORRANCE
ARMAND BUSINESS AGENT WITH
SPRINKLER FITTERS LOCAL FORTY
THREE IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA I STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES AND
OPPOSE SIXTY SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN IN AB AND S. B. ONE
THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU RYAN ONE NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S SHANE
BOSTON BUSINESS MANAGER OF
LOCAL FORTY FOUR PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS VENTURA COUNTY WE
STAND WITH STATE BUILDING
TRADES. IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF
SECTION SIXTY SEVEN OF S. B.
ONE THIRTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT ONE FORTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS RANDY WIPER IRONWORKERS
LOCAL FOUR SIXTEEN LOS ANGELES.
WHICH STAMP WHAT STATE BUILDING
TRADES OPPOSING SECTION. SIXTY
SEVEN OF S. B. ONE THIRTY TWO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH HI YET THE GREATER THE
OFFERING ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE
AND I'M GOING TO THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN THEIR
OPPOSITION SENATE BILL ONE
THIRTY PM SECTION SIXTY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TO
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY
NINE SHUTTLE SHELTER ABOLISHING
TEACHER AND PARENT ENDED STUDY.
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF A
GROUP OF OVER 4% VALLEY
FAMILIES THAT YOU DIDN'T AND
THE PROGRAMS WE CLOSED CHANGE
IN CREDIT A LOT THE EXEMPTION
AND TWAIN AND CHARTER SCHOOLS
SB ACTUALLY WE NEED
OPPORTUNITIES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU RIGHT ONCE I SO
TO BE GO AHEAD. YOU THAT THIS
FRANK UNANIMOUS PRESIDENT BUSH
WORKERS. FOUR SIX. JOINING THE
STATE BILLION TRADE ENOUGH OF
SB ONE THIRTY TWO SECTION SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
SEVEN FOUR CALL. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS RJ FERRARI BUSINESS
REP UA LOCAL THIRTY SAN
FRANCISCO WE OPPOSE SB ONE
THIRTY TWO SECTION SIXTY SEVEN
WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU RYAN TO EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN ONE
WITH THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS WHICH LEADS
CALIFORNIANS FOR COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY A DIVERSE
COALITION UNITED AND
STRENGTHENING STATE NEED BASED
FINANCIAL AID SO THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN AFFORD TO
SUCCESSFULLY EARN A HIGHER
EDUCATION CREDENTIAL. WE'RE
INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
BUDGET HISTORIC INVESTMENTS IN
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY AND AN
ENTITLEMENT CAL GRANT HER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS IN
PARTICULAR WHICH SERVE THE
MAJORITY OF THE STATE'S LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND STUDENTS OF
COLOR. CRITICAL POLICY CHANGE
AND CORRESPONDING MONEY MENTAL
INVESTMENT WILL GO FAR IN
SUPPORTING THE LEAST RESOURCE
CALIFORNIANS AND WE APPLAUD
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND SUSTAINED
COMMITMENT TO HIGHER EDUCATION
EQUITY AFFORDABILITY. ACCESS
AND SUCCESS. THANK YOU RIGHT
ONE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARTHA CALLING
ON THE LOCAL FIVE FORTY NINE
WELL THE MAKERS AND WE ARE
STANDING IN OPPOSITION- SB
THIRTY SEVEN. I'M BY THIRTY TWO.
THANK YOU RIGHT MORE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M DAVID BEANIE
REPRESENTING THE MEN AND WOMEN
OF THE SANTA CLARA AND SAN
BENITO COUNTIES BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL WE
STAND WITH A STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
SECTION SIXTY SEVEN OF EIGHTY
ONE THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN TO SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. STEP THERE ARE
WILSHIRE TEN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. EDDIE GONZALEZ
CALLING FROM SAN FRANCISCO
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL ON BEHALF OF OUR THIRTY
CHIU UNIONS IN THE CITY OF TEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS FOURTEEN
HUNDRED APPRENTICES AND NOW
FIFTEEN HUNDRED ON THE OUT OF
WORK BUT WE HAVE TO OPPOSE
SECTION SIXTY SEVEN THE
OUTSOURCING PROVISION- LOOK WE
GET THE SPIRIT OF IT WE WENT
PICKET LINES WE'VE BEEN IN
SOLIDARITY WITH ASKED ME. BUT
THIS IS A CYNICAL ATTEMPT I LED
A DELEGATION AND SAN FRANCISCO
MAY SIXTEENTH TWENTY NINETEEN
AND WE GOT ARRESTED TO FIGHT
AND WIN THIS AND ABSOLUTELY ONE
THIS POLICY AT THE REGION'S AND
THEN THEY WON THE CONTRACT
LANGUAGE AND NOW WE ARE BEING
THRUST INTO THE MIDDLE OFA
CYNICAL ATTEMPT THAT WILL
IMPACT OUR JOBS IN. THE HOME
DISTRICT IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
ACROSS THE STATE FROM ECONOMIC
RECOVERY STANDPOINT THIS IS
RECKLESS AND YOU HAVE TO REMOVE
SECTION SIXTY SEVEN WE OPPOSE.
ONE THIRTY TWO OF SIXTY SEVEN
STATEMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
BRING TO SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
TO HELP BURKE OF THE HEAVY
HIGHWAY BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TEAMSTERS
COMMITTEE FOR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE PROUDLY STAND
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION OF SB ONE THIRTY TWO
SECTION SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO OUR SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THE NEW
YORKER SEGA BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE WITH THE
PLUMBERS SPEAKERS AND
REFRIGERATION SERVICE
TECHNICIAN OF SANTA CLARA AND
SAN BENITO COUNTIES WHICH DEALT
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO THE SP
ONE THIRTY TWO SECTIONS SIX-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TO
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JOHN SPALDING REPRESENTING THE
KERN INYO AND MONO COUNTIES
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL. WE ARE JOINING
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
THEIR OPPOSITION TO SECTION
SIXTY SEVEN OF SENATE BILL ONE
THIRTY TWO ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE FIFTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RODRIGUEZ
LOCAL TO FIFTY STANFORD
REFRIGERATION BARTENDERS WE
STAND 1100% YEAH THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORT THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU RYAN ONE FIFTY THREE PLEASE
CALL AT. GOOD AFTERNOON ROMA
LLOYD CENTER NATIONAL VICE
PRESIDENT THE TEAMSTERS
REPRESENTING TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND MEMBERS IN THE STATE
ESPECIALLY OUR FOURTEEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF THE UC
SYSTEM WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
SECTION SIXTY SEVEN IN THIS
BILL THAT. WOULD HELP IN A
WOULD BE REMOVED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU RIGHT TO NINETY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON JOSH TAKEN ON BEHALF
OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK TO
DELIVER A HIGHER EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL AND BUDGET PACKAGE
THAT INCLUDES THE STORK
INVESTMENTS TO ENSURE FUTURE
GENERATIONS OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS. WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE STREAMLINED PATHWAYS
TO A COLLEGE DEGREE. GOING IN
AT THE ONE THIRTY JUNE
INVESTMENT TO EXPAND THE CAL
GRANT ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS. AND
LANGUAGE REQUIRE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS TO COMPLETE THE PROPER
CATER TO INCREASE UTILIZATION
OF AVAILABLE FEDERAL FEDERAL A-
PROFOUND IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS AND KEY FINANCIAL
BURDEN THEY BEAR TO PURSUE
HIGHER EDUCATION. WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE PROVIDING BUDGET
ALLOCATIONS AND NOT BE ONE
THIRTY TWO TO SUPPORT GUIDED
PATHWAYS IMPLEMENTATION. THAT
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY COLLEGES
AND THE INVESTMENT IN THE
CRADLE. TO CAREER DATA SYSTEM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TO
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
TOM GILBERT CREATE- FROM LOCAL
BOARD THIRTY ONE JOINT COUNCIL
SEVEN I AM JOINING THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN THEIR
OPPOSITION SB ONE THIRTY TWO
SECTION SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
BETHANY CANTRELL AND THE
PARENTS OF LONGTIME INDEPENDENT
STUDY STUDENTS AND I AM OPPOSED
TO THE PROPOSED CHANGES TO THE
PROGRAM INCLUDED IN SB ONE
THIRTY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RAIN TO NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE ADDRESSING
WITH THE AMERICAN FEDERATION OF
STATE COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
EMPLOYEES YOU'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL ONE
THIRTY TWO SECTION SIXTY SEVEN
RELATING TO UNIVERSE JEFF OF
CALIFORNIA CAPITAL PROJECTS.
STATE DOLLARS SHOULD NOT BE
USED BY THE UC IN A RACE TO THE
BOTTOM BY PRIVATIZING JOBS
CUTTING WAGES CUTTING BENEFITS
AN EMPLOYER ESPECIALLY JUST AS
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND OUR STATE DOLLARS CAN AND
SHOULD DO BETTER. DETECTION
CLOSING THE LOOPHOLE ALLOWING
THE OUTSOURCING KICKING YOUR BY
THE UC THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN THREE OH FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MARK THIS
YEAR AGO THE DS REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER OUR
MEMBERS THANK YOU AND THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR YOUR
CONTINUED SUPPORT AND
COMMITMENT OF PROPOSITION FIFTY
EIGHT OF TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SECTION ONE FIVE EIGHT OF AB
ONE THIRTY WILL PROVIDE NEEDED
RESOURCES FOR THE PURPOSE OF
ESTABLISHING NEW OR EXPANDED
ACCESS TO QUALITY DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNING PROGRAM. THIS ACTION
WILL PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS TO OBTAIN ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE SKILLS NECESSARY TO BE
ABLE TO COMPETE IN A GLOBAL
SOCIETY AND ECONOMY AGAIN THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU A LINE
THREE OH SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
GRETCHEN NEWSOM ON BEHALF OF
IBEW LOCAL FIVE SIX NINE IN OUR
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED UNION
ELECTRICIANS AND WORKING
FAMILIES ACROSS SAN DIEGO AND
IMPERIAL COUNTY. ANY MENTALITY
ALREADY WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
SECTION SIXTY SEVEN OF EIGHTY
ONE THIRTY TWO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OF MINE THREE OR NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI DOUG BLOCK
REPRESENTING MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND TEAMSTERS IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA WHICH I
COUNCIL SEVEN INCLUDING WORKERS
IN THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM AND THEN THE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES WHO WE
ARE STANDING IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF IN OUR OPPOSITION TO SECTION
SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RYAN THREE TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS JOHN HERSHEY AND I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL FOUR FOUR
SEVEN TO STRONGLY OPPOSE
SECTION SIXTY SEVEN OF AB IN SB
ONE THIRTY TWO BECAUSE OF THE
HARMFUL TO OUR MEMBERSHIP BY
THREATENING TO STALL OR CCC
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS BY
CONSTRAINING THE ABILITY OF THE
UNIVERSITY OFCALIFORNIA TO
FINANCE CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS.
AS WE ALL KNOW CONSTRUCTION
LIMINAL AND SO POSSIBLY
DELAYING OR TERMINATING
PROJECTS OF ANY SCALE BECAUSE
OF FINANCIAL CONSTRAINTS WOULD
MEAN THAT OUR MEMBERSHIP WILL
BE UNABLE TO EARN THEIR INCOMES
TO SUPPORT THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
DO NOT HAVE THE LUXURY OF YEAR
ROUND WORK AND WHILE I
PERSONALLY UNDERSTAND THE
DESIRE TO CONFIRM 1100% DIRECT
EMPLOYMENT FOR SERVICE WORK AT
YOU SEE FACILITIES SECTION
SIXTY SEVEN OF ASSEMBLY
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE BILLS ONE
THIRTY TWO RESPONDING TO
STRUCTURE WORKERS OUT OF WORK
ON SOCIALLY NECESSARY AND
CRITICAL MUCH MEDICAL PROJECTS
AND SO ON WITH IN THE UC
SYSTEM. YEARS NEITHER OF THESE
BILLS TO BE PASSED WITH THE
LANGUAGE INCLUDED IN SECTION
SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU RYAN THREE
ARRIVING PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI WE
ARE JACKSON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB
ONE THIRTY TWO SECTION SIXTY
SEVEN BILLION A REPRESENTS
THOUSANDS OF REGISTERED NURSES
AT UT MEDICAL CENTER AND HAS
HISTORICALLY SUPPORTED OUR
FELLOW YOU SEE UNION COALITION
MEMBERS ALONG WITH OPPOSING THE
PRACTICE OF CONTRACTING OUT
HOWEVER. BNA'S VERY CONCERN
THAT IF ENACTED THIS WOULD STOP
OR SLOW CRUCIAL SEISMIC SAFETY
RETROFIT AND REBUILD
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT AT UC
HOSPITAL WHICH ARE LEGALLY
REQUIRED TO BE FINISHED IN THE
NEXT EIGHT AND A HALF YEARS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. AND I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY SUGGEST THAT
RATHER THAN HOLDING VITAL
CONSTRUCTION MONEY HOSTAGE THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AS
AMENDED TO PUT A HALT ON ALL
EXECUTIVE BONUSES EXECUTIVE PAY
INCREASES IN THE UC REGENTS PER
DIEM AND POLICE AUDIT CAN BE
COMPLETED AND CERTIFIED BY A
THIRD PARTY. OUR PATIENTS IN
YOUR CONSTITUENTS SHOULD NOT BE
THE ONE TO SUFFER BECAUSE OF UC
ADMINISTRATORS AGREE JUST
CONTRACTING OUT PRACTICE. FOR
THIS REASON THE AND I MUST
REGRETFULLY REQUEST YOU REJECT
PROPOSED BUDGET TRAILER BILL
UNTIL THIS PROBLEMATIC LANGUAGE
IS REMOVED OR AMENDED TO
ADDRESS OUR PATIENT. SAFETY
CONCERNS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M THREE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
FRED JONES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS EDUCATION
ASSOCIATION. NEXT CALL ABOUT SB
ONE THIRTY AND THE A. THREE G.
COMPLETION GRANT- WHILE WE
SUPPORT EVERY STUDENT HAVING
ACCESS TO COLLEGE PREP WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THIS COULD
SQUEEZE OUT NON A TO G.
APPROVED CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION COURSES SO WE
CERTAINLY WOULD HOPE. THAT
AFTER THE LEGISLATURE HAS PUT
SO MUCH EFFORT IN REBUILDING
HIGH QUALITY INDUSTRY LINE C.
T. THAT THERE COULD BE SOME
SORT OF HOLD HARMLESS- LANGUAGE
INSERTED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU RYAN THREE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHRIS GRIBBLE
ORGANIZER WITH ROAD SPRINKLER
FITTERS LOCAL UNION SIX SIX
NINE WITH THIRTEEN THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED MEMBERS WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED. U. S. B. ONE
THIRTY JUNE SECTION SIXTY SEVEN
AND WE ARE PROUD TO STAND WITH
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN THREE
AWAIT PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE WOULD
HOPE YEAH. THANK ZERO EIGHT H.
I MEAN IN YOUR THAT ALBUM.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
AND I LIVE IN ORANGE I'VE BEEN
HOME FOR MY CHILDREN FOR THE
LAST NINE YEARS. IN OUTSIDE ARE
DEFENDING EXPANDING R. CARE
FIRST GENERATION. AND I. AB ONE
THIRTEEN BECAUSE THIS IS GOING
TO INTERFERE AND HURT CHILDREN.
MY CHILDREN AT SCHOOL- CHOI
SAID. I BEG YOU TO EVERYONE WHO
READS A POEM SB ONE THIRTY AND.
NINETY ONE THIRTY THANK YOU.
YOUR ANSWER SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHO WOULD HAVE. ROBIN RIEGER
AWAY YOUR- GO FROM THE LABEL
YOU KNOW OVER TO SEVENTY WE
HAVE SORRY DADI WE GOT CUT
STATE THREE IN A POSITION OF
SEXUAL SEVEN AB AND THEN WE
WANT TO TWO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT. THREE ONE EIGHT. AND I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR JUST GONNA SEE ANY
FURTHER COMMENT FROM THE-
COMMITTEE ROOM. AND I'M NOT
SEEING ANY FURTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATOR WE WILL
ADJOURN.